आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
ओके आई थिंक आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ राइट
ओके
ओके सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ एम ऑडिबल
एंड विज़िबल गाइस प्लीज लेट मी नो
प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरीबडी
ओके मेरी ऑडियो वीडियो आप सभी को आ रही है
लाउड एंड क्लियर प्लीज बता दीजिए सभी बता
दीजिए फटाफट
गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते अ वेरी गुड इवनिंग एंड
नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सभी लोग आ रहे हैं धीरे-धीरे आने दीजिए
सभी को
ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए। सो
ओके। मैं एक बार अ मैं अपने साइड पे चेक
कर लेता हूं। जस्ट अ सेकंड।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। काफी लोग आ चुके हैं। अ वी आर वेटिंग
फॉर सम मोर पीपल टू जॉइन द सेशन। गुड
इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते।
चलिए अभी नोटिफिकेशन गई होगी तो लोगों को
आने देते हैं पहले। सभी को आ जाने देते
हैं। एक बार आ जाएंगे फिर स्टार्ट करेंगे
अपन।
ठीक है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। सो
अ
वो थोड़े से लेंथ वो बड़े कर रहे हैं ना
इसलिए इस वजह से ठीक है सर टुडे इज़ माय
फर्स्ट क्लास कैन आई गेट द पीपीटी यस
श्योरली आप WhatsApp ग्रुप ज्वाइन कर
लीजिए यू विल डेफिनेटली गेट द पीपीटी
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में WhatsApp
ग्रुप का लिंक होता है ठीक है सो सभी को
एक बार जॉइन करने देते हैं उसके पहले
फटाफट मैं आपको बता देता हूं YouTube पे
सबसे पहले आपको काम करना है YouTube पे
जाना डिफ़्रॉनिक्स Aady YouTube चैनल को
ओपन कर लेना है आपको। यहां लाइव सेक्शन
में जाना है और एसओसी वाली कोई सी भी
प्रीवियस क्लास की वीडियो को ओपन कर
लीजिएगा। एंड इस वीडियो के भी
डिस्क्रिप्शन और डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको
लिंक मिल जाएंगे। जिसके डिस्क्रिप्शन को
एक्सपैंड करेंगे। आपको दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे।
एक WhatsApp चैनल का आपको लिंक मिलेगा, एक
ग्रुप का मिलेगा। दोनों को ओपन कर लीजिएगा
दो टैब में। WhatsApp चैनल को फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा क्योंकि यह इसलिए जरूरी है
क्योंकि जितने भी अपडेट्स हमारे साइड से
होते हैं रिगार्डिंग एनी काइंड ऑफ कोर्सेज
ये करंट एसओसी का या अपकमिंग ट्रेनिंग्स
का या व्हाटएवर रिसोर्सेज आर देयर जो भी
चीजें होती है सबसे पहले आपको इसी चैनल पे
मिलेगी देखने को और कहीं भी आपको नहीं
मिलेगी सबसे पहले यहां मिलेगा तो इसको
फॉलो जरूर कर लीजिएगा ठीक है या WhatsApp
चैनल पे आप डिफ्रॉनिक सर्च करके भी आप
इसको फॉलो कर सकते हैं। दूसरा WhatsApp
ग्रुप है जो स्पेशली अह एसओसी अह
एनालिस्ट्स जो इस पूरी सीरीज को देख रहे
हैं। यह ग्रुप उनके लिए डेडिकेटेड है। तो
जितने भी लाइक आपको रिसोर्सेज या नोट्स या
जो भी चीजें आपको हैं इस ट्रेनिंग के
रिगार्डिंग इस सीरीज के रिगार्डिंग वो
आपको सबसे पहले इसी ग्रुप में और सिर्फ और
सिर्फ इसी ग्रुप में मिलती है। तो इसको भी
जरूर जॉइ कर लीजिएगा। द थर्ड इज़ द ये
Lindin पेज प्रोफाइल है मेरा। आप मुझसे
यहां पे आके कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। Lindin
पे आके 13,000 लोग लगभग मुझसे कनेक्ट हुए
हैं यहां पे। आप भी आके मुझसे कनेक्ट कर
सकते हैं। साथ ही Lindin पे अगर आप
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करते हैं। सो यू विल
फाइंड द Lindin पेज ऑफ़ डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। हमारी कंपनी की जो पेज है
यहां आपको हमारी कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग
कंपनी की तरफ से जो भी अपडेट्स हैं, जो भी
हमने जो भी हम आगे प्रोसेस है, जो भी
चीजें कर रहे हैं वो सारी चीजें जो है
आपको यहां पे देखने को मिल जाती है। तो
इसको जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। कुछ इस तरीके
से आपको दिखेगी यह पेज यहां पे एंड यू विल
सी लाइक दिस वन राइट तो यहां पे लगभग
22,000 लोग हमसे जुड़े हैं। यू कैन बी द
पार्ट ऑफ दिस पेज आल्सो यह हमारा
Instagram पेज है। एंड यू कैन डेफिनेटली
कम एंड फॉलो अस हियर फॉर इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल
रील्स, कंटेंट्स, पोस्ट ये सब चीजों के
लिए आप इसको फॉलो कर सकते हैं। साथ ही में
यह हमारा एक्स का पेज है। Twitter पेज। आप
इसको आके फॉलो कर लीजिएगा यहां पे। एंड
देन हमारी वेबसाइट है। वेबसाइट को विजिट
कर सकते हैं। वेबसाइट कंप्लीट रिवैंप और
कंप्लीट न्यू लुक में आने वाली है। बहुत
जल्द बहुत काफी अच्छा लगेगा आपको वो लुक।
और फिलहाल यहां पे नंबर आपको हमारा मिल
जाएगा। इस पे आप हमसे WhatsApp पे किसी
तरह की क्वेरी क्वेश्चंस कर सकते हैं।
एकडमी पे जाके हमारे कोर्सर्सेस को
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। ये मेरा खुद का
पर्सनल Instagram पेज है। आप आके मुझसे
यहां पे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। सो ये पूरी
सोशल जो प्रोफाइलिंग है वो थी जो मैंने
आपको बता दी। अब जो है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। बट उसके पहले आज
की जो टॉपिक है वो मैं उसके बारे में
थोड़ा सा आपको मैं डिस्कस करना चाहता हूं।
थोड़ा सा आपसे डिस्कस करना चाहता हूं। ठीक
है? एंड ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट बहुत
बढ़िया। [हंसी]
वेरी गुड वेरी गुड। सो आज जो है मैं यहां
पे क्या बोल रहा है? सर विल यू हैव अ नहीं
भाई मैं नहीं करता यार।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
मैं नहीं करता। चलिए आज जो है हम एक बहुत
ही शानदार टॉपिक के ऊपर आने वाले हैं।
बहुत ही शानदार टॉपिक को करने वाले हैं।
कवर करने वाले हैं। एंड ये जो टॉपिक है वो
मतलब बिलीव मी दिस इज़ अ
क्वालिटी टॉपिक। यह टॉपिक ऐसी टॉपिक है जो
आपके लिए बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है।
हालांकि मैं जो भी टॉपिक्स आपके लिए लेकर
आता हूं एसओसी के अंदर में वह बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट ही होते हैं आपके इस जर्नी के
लिए क्योंकि आप एक प्रोफेशनल बनना चाहते
हैं। एक प्रोफेशनल बनेंगे तो उस केस में
इन टॉपिक्स को गो थ्रू करना बहुत ज्यादा
मस्ट है। क्योंकि जब आप इंटरव्यू के लिए
जाते हैं तो वहां पे आपको ये क्वेश्चंस
इन्हीं टॉपिक्स से रहेंगे। डेफिनेटली मैं
आपको
यकीन के साथ कह सकता हूं कि जब आप
इंटरव्यू के लिए जाएंगे तो आपको इन
टॉपिक्स से क्वेश्चंस श्योरली 100% मिलने
वाले हैं। तो प्लीज इन टॉपिक्स को इग्नोर
मत कीजिएगा। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू
एवरीबॉडी। एंड जो लोग नए आए हैं जो लोग
अभी-अभी जुड़े हैं वो लोग लाइक ठोकते
जाइएगा। एंड अभी तो काफी तीन 30 लोग हैं
क्योंकि शायद टाइमिंग का होगा। बट ठीक है
स्टिल वी विल स्टार्ट नाउ। एंड बिफोर वी
स्टार्ट लेट्स सी द टॉपिक हियर। तो आज हम
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं पिरामिड ऑफ पेन और
यूनिफाइड किल चेन के बारे में। ठीक है?
देखो अब ये क्या टॉपिक्स है? मैं आपको
बताता हूं। एसओसी के लिए मैं आपको यहां पे
एक बार नोट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कर
देता हूं।
देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एसओसी के लिए कुछ टॉपिक्स बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है। एक टॉपिक है आपके मत्रे
फ्रेमवर्क। एक टॉपिक है आपका साइबर किलचन।
तीसरा है आपका पिरामिड ऑफ
पेन। एंड चौथा जो है आपका वह है
यूनिफाइड किल चेन।
यूनिफाइड किल चेन यह टॉपिक्स यह जो
टॉपिक्स हैं, ठीक है? यह जो टॉपिक्स हैं,
ये बहुत ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है एज एन
एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट एज अ इंसिडेंट
रिस्पाउडर। आपके लिए बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है। याद रखिएगा इस बात को। इन
टॉपिक्स का अगर कांसेप्ट और आपको क्लेरिटी
नहीं है अगर तो आप एसओसी के इंटरव्यूज
क्लियर नहीं कर पाएंगे। मैं आपको पहले ही
बोल दे रहा हूं। बाद में आप ये मत बोलना
कि सर आपने बताया ही नहीं इन टॉपिक्स के
बारे में। आपने इस पे उतना फोकस नहीं
किया। आपने ये नहीं बोला कि ये इतने
इंपॉर्टेंट थे। हमारे तो इंटरव्यू में
इनसे ही क्वेश्चंस थे। 30- 40% क्वेश्चंस
तो ऐसा एक्चुअली होता है। अलर्ट, ट्रायग,
रिपोर्ट इन सब से तो होता है। बट इनसे
100% आपके क्वेश्चंस इंटरव्यू के अंदर
होगा ही होगा। यह बात गारंटी के साथ मैं
आपको बोल रहा हूं। तो, इस बात को ध्यान
में रखिएगा। अब देखिए इनमें से हम जो
टॉपिक आज करने वाले हैं वो यह लास्ट के
थ्री और फोर टॉपिक हैं। तो नाउ द क्वेश्चन
कैन बी इन योर माइंड व्हाई नॉट द फर्स्ट
टू टॉपिक्स? क्योंकि ये दोनों टॉपिक्स
हमने पहले ही कर लिए हैं। अगर आप में से
कई लोगों को नहीं पता तो मैं आपको ये चीज
एग्जैक्टली बताना चाहता हूं। आपको मैं
दिखा भी देता हूं कैसे कर लिए हमने।
YouTube पे आप जाइएगा। डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी
ओपन कर लीजिएगा। लाइव सेक्शन में जाइएगा।
अब एसओसी की जो क्लासेस हैं उसमें क्लास
नंबर फाइव पे जाइएगा। सबसे पहले तो क्लास
नंबर फाइव यह वाली क्लास। इस क्लास फाइव
का टाइटल देखिए आप अलर्ट रिपोर्टिंग
एस्केलेशन एंड साइबर किल चेन। तो इसमें
मैंने पूरा इन डेप्थ साइबर किल चेन को कवर
करा है। पूरी इन डेप्थ कवर करी है। ऐसा
नहीं है कि इसमें आपको
कोई शॉर्टकट में बताया गया है या ऐसे ओवर
ऊपर ऊपर का कुछ बताया गया है। यहां
कंप्लीट आपका जो है साइबर किल चेन कवर
किया गया है। जिन लोगों ने देखा होगा यह
वीडियो उनको पता होगा कि इट्स बीन कवर्ड
ऑलरेडी। तो इसको जरूर जिन्होंने नहीं देखा
साइबर किल चेन को जरूर एक बार देख
लीजिएगा। आई रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी
स्टार्टिंग से ही मैंने पहले साइबर किल
चेन ही बताया है। बाद में इसमें
रिपोर्टिंग एस्केलेशन वगैरह बताया है। तो
ये इंपॉर्टेंट है। अब आज की क्लास से इसका
कोई लेना देना नहीं है। यूनिफाइड किलचेन
एक अलग चीज है। पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन अलग चीज
है। बट स्टिल इसको जरूर कर लीजिएगा। ठीक
है? साइबर किलचेन। अब आते हैं मैत्रे पे।
अब देखो मत्री अटैक जो है उसको उस पे बहुत
डिटेल में यहां पे ट्रेनिंग यहां पे आपको
वीडियो हमारे साइड से आपको दी गई है आपको
यहां पे ऐसे कहीं दिख नहीं रहा होगा शायद
इस तरीके से सामने से कुछ दिख नहीं रहा
होगा आपको Myra के ऊपर राइट कि यहां सर
कहां है आपके Myro Myra आपने देखो देखो
यहां पे कहां पे आपने My किया है लेकिन
Myra के ऊपर पूरी डिटेल्ड वीडियो आई है।
आप इसके लिए लाइव सेक्शन में नहीं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वीडियो
सेक्शन में जाइएगा इन द वीडियो सेक्शन एंड
यहां पे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आपको
हमारा जो दो वीक पहले हमने वीडियो डाली थी
मित्र्रे अटैक फॉर एसोसिएशन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी ये लगभग एक घंटे की ये वीडियो
है इस वीडियो को जरूर देखिएगा यह वीडियो
इन डेप्थ मत को कवर करता है मत बोल लो
बहुत लोग मित्र्रे बोलते हैं बहुत लोग
एमआईटीआर ही बोलते हैं कुछ भी बोल लो फर्क
नहीं पड़ता है बहुत लोग इसको मत फेम को
पूरा कवर किया गया है। बहुत इन डेप्थ और
पूरी डिटेल में कवर की गई है। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यह जो है मत
वीडियो यह जरूर देखिएगा। इसके अलावा साइबर
किल चैन का डेडिकेटेड वीडियो भी हमने डाला
है एक और मैंने तो बताया ही था आपको बट एक
डेडिकेटेड वीडियो भी लगभग 30 मिनट का
साइबर किल चैन का डला हुआ है। तो आप इसको
भी देख सकते हैं। मेरी वाली क्लास तो
देखिएगा ही देखिएगा। उसके बाद भी अगर आपको
देखना हो तो यह वीडियो आप देख लीजिएगा। यह
डेडिकेटेड डली हुई है। उसके बाद मतरी अटैक
जो है यह जरूर देखिएगा। बस जैसे ही आप यह
देख लेते हैं तो आपका यह पहला दो कंप्लीट
हो जाता है। दिस इज़ वेरीेंट
वेरी वेरीेंट फॉर एसओसी। याद रखिएगा बाद
में आपसे यह नहीं सुनने चाहिए मैं कि सर
आपने तो बताया ही नहीं कि इतना इंपॉर्टेंट
था। इंटरव्यू में इसी से क्वेश्चन जो है
वो पूछ रहे थे। राइट?
कोई बात नहीं। रिक्वेथ बॉल मैं अभी बहुत
डिटेल में बताने वाला हूं। आप उसको
देखिएगा। ठीक है? चलिए नाउ वी आर कमिंग ऑन
द
टॉपिक ऑन द टॉपिक जो आज हम करने वाले हैं।
ठीक है? लेट्स सी जो भी आए हैं, लाइक ठोक
दीजिएगा फटाफट एंड शेयर कर दीजिएगा लोगों
के बीच वीडियो को। सबसे पहले हम पिरामिड
ऑफ पेन को पढ़ने वाले हैं। स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं। सो एवरीवन। अच्छा मुझे आप लोगों
में से पहले बता दीजिए यार। पहले आप लोगों
में से सभी लोग बताइए कि मथ्रे और साइबर
किल चेन वाली वीडियो कितने लोगों ने देख
ली है अभी तक? वीडियो और जो लाइव थी दोनों
मिला के मतलब कितने लोगों ने देख ली आप
में से? बताइए जरा
एसओसी वर्क फ्रॉम होम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एमएसएसपी की तरह ही कर सकते हैं। ऐसे तो
नहीं कर सकते आप। एमएसएसपी की तरह आप कर
सकते हैं। वैसे नहीं कर सकते आप।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नॉट एवरीवन इज रेसोंडिंग अ क्या हुआ
प्लीज रेस्पोंड एवरीबडी
एवरीबडी प्लीज रिसोंड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
आ गया।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वैसे नहीं कर सकते।
ओके। सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नीरज आपके क्वेश्चन का आंसर दे दिया है।
फिर भी अगर आप स्पैम कर रहे हैं तो आपको
फिर हम यहां पे टाइम आउट कर देते हैं
थोड़ी देर के लिए। प्लीज डोंट स्पैम। ठीक
है?
चलिए अ सो
कई लोगों के आंसर आए हैं। कुछ लोगों ने
किया है। कुछ लोगों ने नहीं किया है। बट
कई लोगों के आंसर नहीं आया है। आई
एक्सपेक्ट एटलीस्ट रिस्पांस फ्रॉम यू
गाइस। एटलीस्ट आप रिप्लाई और रिस्पांस
किया कीजिए ताकि मुझे पता चले कि आप अभी
क्लास में ही हैं और आप इंटरेस्ट शो कर
रहे हैं। राइट? अदरवाइज क्या फायदा लाइव
में आने का? राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नहीं ऐसा कुछ नहीं है। हरिक वेद पॉल जैसा
जब रिक्वायरमेंट है उसके अकॉर्डिंग मैं
लाता रहूंगा। ठीक है? बेफिक्र रहिए आप
उसके लिए।
ठीक है?
ओके। चलिए चलिए। सो लेट्स स्टार्ट। लेट्स
स्टार्ट। पहले अब सभी लोग प्लीज फोकस हियर
एंड वी आर गोइंग टू स्टार्ट द टॉपिक। सो
प्लीज फोकस फॉर नाउ हियर। ओके? सभी लोग
फोकस कीजिए यहां पे।
ओके लेट्स गो। चलिए लेट्स स्टार्ट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो हम आज समझने वाले हैं पिरामिड ऑफ पेन
के बारे में। वी आर गोइंग टू अंडरस्टैंड
अबाउट पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन। ठीक है? पिरामिड ऑफ
पेन क्या होता है? ठीक है? देखो अभी तक
आपने साइबर किल चैन पढ़ा था, अह माइथ्रे
फेम पढ़ा था। ये सारी चीजें पढ़ी थी। राइट?
अब देखो पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन क्या होता है? द
पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन इज़ वन ऑफ़ द मोस्ट
फंडामेंटल कांसेप्ट्स इन मॉडर्न साइबर
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस एंड एसओसी ऑपरेशंस। सो,
यह एक ऐसा कांसेप्ट है जो सीटीआई का भी
कांसेप्ट है साइबर थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस का।
तो अगर आप थ्रेट हंटिंग, थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
वगैरह में जाते हैं तो भी आपको इस टॉपिक
की जानकारी होनी मस्ट है और अगर आप एसओसी
के लिए जाते हैं फिर तो होनी ही है। ठीक
है? तो साइबर थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस एंड
ऑपरेशंस एसओसी वाले दोनों में इंपॉर्टेंट
है। इंट्रोड्यूस बाय सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर
डेविड जे बैंको इन 2013 2013 में ये
इंट्रोड्यूस हुई थी। सोचो हम सोचते हैं ना
कि हम क्या इन्वेंट करें? सब चीजें तो
ऑलरेडी प्रेजेंट है। हम क्या चीज़ ऐसे लाए?
सोचो दिस इज़ वन ऑफ़ द कॉनंसेप्ट डिलीिवर्ड
इन 2013 बाय अ सिक्योरिटी रिस्चर जो आज हम
पढ़ रहे हैं। सो कभी भी कुछ भी हो सकता है।
राइट? इट इलस्ट्रेट्स द रिलेशनशिप बिटवीन
द टाइप्स ऑफ इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज।
यू यूज़ टू डिटेक्ट एन एडवर्सरी एंड द
अमाउंट ऑफ पेन यू कॉज द अटैकर व्हेन यू
डिनाई देम दोज़ इंडिकेटर्स।
इसका मतलब क्या है? यह जो पिरामिड ऑफ पेन
है, यह किस चीज के लिए यूज में लिया जाता
है? यह एक रिलेशनशिप डेवलप करता है। बताता
है किसके बीच में? इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज के बीच में। इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ़
कॉम्प्रोमाइज क्या होते हैं? जब कोई भी एक
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ब्रीच हो जाता है या कोई
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाती है,
नेटवर्क कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाता है तो वहां
जो इंडिकेटर्स का यूज़ किया गया होता है,
जो इंडिकेटर्स का वहां पे इंडिकेटर्स से
हमें पता चलता है कि एक्सैक्टली ये चीज
ब्रीच हुई है, ये चीजें कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुई
है। तो, उसके बीच का रिलेशनशिप
जो है, यह क्या करता है? टाइप्स ऑफ
इंडिकेटर्स हम जो यूज करते हैं टू डिटेक्ट
एन एनिवर्सरी एंड द अमाउंट ऑफ पेन। और जो
पेन एक अटैकर को एज अ सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट
आप देने वाले हैं। कैसे? उस अटैक को एक
पर्टिकुलर इंडिकेटर ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज पे
रोक के।
इसी को कहते हैं पिरामिड ऑफ वेन।
सिंपल। इसी को कहते हैं पिरामिड ऑफ क्वेन।
मतलब कि जो इंडिकेटर ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज
आपने सेटअप किया है। किस लिए किया है?
ताकि पता चले कि डेटा ब्रीच अगर कोई हुई
है या कोई अटैक हुआ है किसी अह
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन पे किसी नेटवर्क के
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया गया
है किसी पर्टिकुलर चीज को तो वहां पे
इंडिकेटर ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज से पता चल जाता
है कि एक्सैक्टली किस तरह का ये अटैक है।
किस तरह से ये कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ है। राइट?
तो अगर हमने उसी चीज को वहां पे डिनाई कर
दिया। हमने उसी चीज को वहां पे पकड़ लिया
और अटैकर के उस पर्टिकुलर अटैक को हमने
वहां पे रोक दिया तो उनको बहुत पेन होगा।
मतलब कि उनको बहुत पीड़ा होगी, दुख होगा
उनको। तो उसी दुख और हमारे इंडिकेटर के
बीच की एक रिलेशनशिप को बताता है पिरामिड
ऑफ़ पेन। दैट्स इट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] द कोर
फिलॉसफी इज़ सिंपल। इसका कोर फिलॉसफी सिंपल
है। नॉट ऑल थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस इज़ क्रिएटेड
इक्वल। सारे थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस इक्वल नहीं
होते हैं। ब्लॉकिंग सम इंडिकेटर्स। अगर
कुछ इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज जिसको आप
ब्लॉक कर देते हैं जिससे पता चल रहा है
अच्छा अच्छा पर्टिकुलर ये फाइल मलिशियस
फाइल के कारण ये अटैक हुआ है। आपने उसको
ब्लॉक कर दिया उस अटैक को। ऑनगोइंग एक
अटैक है। एक अटैक ऑलरेडी चल रही है। उसको
आपने ब्लॉक कर दिया। राइट? तो ब्लॉकिंग सम
इंडिकेटर्स फोर्सर्सेस एंड अटैकर टू
स्पेंड फाइव सेकंड्स चेंजिंग अ लाइन ऑफ़
कोड। कुछ जगह पे जब आप ब्लॉक करेंगे इस
अटैक्स को, तो अटैकर क्या करेगा? कुछ लाइन
ऑफ़ कोड्स को चेंज करेगा और वापस से एक्टिव
हो जाएगा। उसके लिए बहुत इजी है। बट वहीं
पे ब्लॉकिंग ऑफ सम ब्लॉकिंग अदर
फोर्सर्सेस ब्लॉकिंग अदर्स या वहीं पे अगर
कुछ अलग तरीके से या कुछ अलग चीजें भी आप
ब्लॉक कर देते हैं तो फोर्स देम टू स्पेंड
सिक्स मंथ्स रिीडाजाइनिंग देयर एंटायर
टूलकिट तो ऐसा भी होता है कि कभी-कभी आपके
ब्लॉकेज करने से उनको जो अटैकर्स होते हैं
उनको महीनों लग जाते हैं उनको पूरा का
पूरा अपना अटैक फ्लो डिजाइन करने में वापस
से वापस से टूलकिट तैयार करने में अटैक
प्रोसेस करने में सारा कुछ करने में तो
कहीं-कहीं ब्लॉक की वजह से कुछ ही सेकंड्स
के लिए अटैकर को पॉज किया जाता है। अटैकर
वापस से एक्टिव हो जाते हैं। कॉम्प्रोमाइज
कर लेते हैं। कहीं-कहीं महीनों फिर लग
जाते हैं। तो डिफरेंस रहता है ये जो इन
थ्रेट जो लेवल थ्रेट थ्रेट लेवल ऑफ़ थ्रेट
है और जिस तरीके से वो कैलकुलेट किए जा
रहे हैं उनके उनका डिफरेंस होता है। वो
एग्जैक्टली हर चीज के लिए इक्वल नहीं होता
है। तो पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन में कुछ ऐसा ही
होता है। अब मैं आपको बताता हूं कि
एग्जैक्टली पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन किस तरीके का
दिखता है। देखो,
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन में यह कुछ इस तरीके से छह
जो है ना छह ये आपको दिख रहे होंगे। ये
हैश वैल्यू, आईपी एड्रेस,
डोमेन नेम्स, नेटवर्क होस्ट आर्टिफेक्ट्स,
टूल्स, टीटीपीस। ये छह इसके पार्ट्स होते
हैं पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन के। कुछ इस तरीके से
ये मेंशन होते हैं। पिरामिड के स्ट्रक्चर
में होते हैं और
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नीचे से अपवर्ड की तरफ हम जाते हैं। ये
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस फ्रेमवर्क कहलाता है
पिरामिड ऑफ पेन। इसको हम थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
फ्रेमवर्क बोलते हैं। ठीक है? जैसे आपका
साइबर किल चेन फ्रेमवर्क है, मथ्रे है।
उसी तरीके से ये भी है। अब देखो
यहां पे
पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन का डेफिनेशन सिंपल वर्ड्स
में बता दिया। भाई कहां तुम लेट जॉइ किए
हो क्या? अभी तो बताया। अभी जस्ट वही तो
बताया पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन क्या होता है। अब
देखो फिर से मैं रिपीट जब करूंगा तो आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा। अब नीचे से ऊपर की तरफ
जब बढ़ते हैं तो क्या होता है? सबसे पहले
हैश वैल्यू होती है। ये है स्मालेस्ट
अटैकर पेन इजी फॉर देम टू चेंज। अब ये हैश
वैल्यू को अगर हम कुछ ब्लॉक करते हैं हैश
वैल्यू के ऊपर जो अटैक्स को अगर ब्लॉक
करते हैं तो ये इजी है ये अटैकर के लिए
आराम से इसको चेंज कर सकता है। उसके बाद
आता है IP एड्रेस। तो यहां पर यह
डिस्पोजेबल इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर होता है।
क्विक फॉर अटैकर्स टू स्वाइप। तुरंत आईपी
स्वाइपिंग कर लेंगे, आईपी चेंज कर लेंगे,
आईपी मास्क कर लेंगे। राइट? तो ये आसान
होता है उनके लिए। डोमेन नेम्स रिक्वायर्स
रजिस्ट्रेशन स्लाइट एनंस फॉर अटैकर्स।
तीसरा होता है डोमेन नेम। कि हम हमने
डोमेन को ब्लॉक कर दिया। पहले हमने हैश
वैल्यू को ब्लॉक किया। तो हैश वैल्यू चेंज
करना बहुत आसान है। राइट?
राइट? उसके बाद यहां पे है IP एड्रेस। IP
एड्रेस में क्या है? यहां पर सब थोड़ा सा
लाइक डिस्पजेबल इंस्ट्रास्ट्रक्चर होता
है। क्विक होता है। नहीं यह सात से
स्टार्ट नहीं होता है। नेक्स्ट हैकर जी
दिस दिस विल स्टार्ट फ्रॉम ज़ीरो वन से
नीचे से स्टार्ट होता है। ठीक है?
डाउनवर्ड्स अपवर्ड्स। ठीक है? फ्रॉम डाउन
टू अप। ऐसे जाएगा ये। डोमेन नेम्स क्या
होता है? स्लाइट एनवाइंग होता है अटैकर्स
के लिए। क्योंकि डोमेन नेम्स के लिए आपको
रजिस्टर करना पड़ता है डोमेनस को। राइट?
उसके बाद आती है नेटवर्क या होस्ट
आर्टिफेक्ट्स। यूनिक ट्रेसेस ऑन द सिस्टम
फोर्सर्सेस कोड चेंजेस। अब नेटवर्क होस्ट
आर्टिफेक्चर के जगह पे अगर इस लेवल पे अगर
कोई ब्लॉकेज आपने करा है अटैक को रोक रहे
हैं आप अटैकर के तो उस अटैकर को बड़ा
गुस्सा आएगा फिर क्योंकि यहां पे कोड में
चेंजेस करने पड़ेंगे अटैकर को। तो अटैकर
विल गेट एंग्री। उसके बाद आता है टूल्स।
न्यूट्रलाइजेस देयर प्राइमरी वेपंस। हाई
इंजीनियरिंग कॉस्ट। अब आपने टूल को ही
न्यूट्रलाइज कर दिया। अटैकर कोई टूल यूज़
कर रहा है मिड जैसे टूल। कोबाल्ट स्ट्राइक
जैसे टूल। अब आपने उसी टूल को बंद कर
दिया। तो, यह तो बहुत बड़ी बात हो गई ना
टूल ही खत्म अटैकर का। अब अटैकर यहां पे
पिस ऑफ कर जाएगा। बहुत गुस्सा आएगा उसको
कि अरे भाई यार, हमारा टूल ही खत्म कर
दिया। उसके बाद आती है टीटीपीस जिसके बारे
में हमने पहले भी पढ़ा हुआ है। आप एसओसी
की क्लासेस को देख सकते हैं। उसमें
टीटीपीस मैंने बताया हुआ है। टैक्टिक्स,
टेक्निक्स एंड प्रोसीजर्स। लास्ट में
हमारा ये सीवियर होता है। इसमें क्या होता
है? ब्लॉक्स कोर बिहेवियर। फर्सेस अटैकर
टू रीइन्वेंट देयर प्रोसेस। अब इसके कोर
बिहेवियर को ही यानी कि जो अटैक है उसके
पूरे वर्क फ्लो को ही यहां पे ब्लॉक कर
दिया जाता है। एंड इस केस में अब जो क्या
होता है अटैकर अटैकर बहुत ज्यादा गुस्से
में आ जाता है। एंड अटैकर बोलता है कि अब
तुम मैं कुछ भी बोल लो अब मैं कुछ नहीं कर
सकता। अब मेरी सारी अटैक्स को ब्लॉक कर दी
गई है। अब मैं कुछ नया तरीका ट्राई
करूंगा। आई विल ट्राई समथिंग समथिंग न्यू
क्योंकि नाउ माय अटैक हैज़ फेल्ड। तो ये एक
तरीका होता है पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन। एक अटैकर
के अटैक को पहले लोअर लेवल पे
एक लोअर लेवल पे लोअर इंपैक्ट के साथ
रोकना। फिर उससे ऊपर फिर उससे ऊपर ऐसे
करते-करते एक उसका जो सबसे हाईएस्ट
इंपैक्ट वाला टूलकिट है उसको रोक देना।
जो कि उसका बेसिकली कोर बिहेवियर होता है
उस तो उसी तरीके से यह नीचे से ऊपर जाती
है। पहले ये ट्रिवियल फज़ होता है।
ट्रिवियल मतलब नॉर्मल सा फिर उस ईजी फिर
सिंपल फिर एनवाइंग गुस दिमाग खराब करने
वाला हट हैकर का। फिर चैलेंजिंग हैकर की
बैंड बजती है। हैकर को लगता है क्या हो
रहा है? सीवियर मतलब पूरा का पूरा खत्म।
तो यह पेन कॉज टू अटैकर। मतलब नीचे से ऊपर
की तरफ पेन बढ़ता चला जा रहा है अटैकर के
लिए। पहले अटैकर को थोड़ा कम पेन है।
अटैकर को कम गुस्सा है। फिर बाद में
धीरे-धीरे गुस्सा बढ़ते-बढ़ते उसका सबसे
ज्यादा गुस्सा आएगा उसको सबसे टॉप पे जो
सबसे ऊपर वाला इसका पिरामिड है। यही है
आपका पिरामिड ऑफ पेन। एक थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
फ्रेमवर्क जिसको यूज़ में लिया जाता है।
अभी इन सारे पार्ट्स को मैं डिटेल में
आपको एक-एक करके समझाऊंगा। आई होप कि आपको
इजी लगेगा क्योंकि#श वैल्यू के बारे में
भी मैंने पहले थोड़ा बहुत बताया है। IPपी
एड्रेस के बारे में मैंने बताया है। डोमेन
नेम्स के बारे में बताया है। नेटवर्क
टूल्स ये सब ये सब चीजें तो आप जनरली
जानते भी हैं, पढ़ते भी हैं। इंटरनेट पे
भी जैसे डोमेन नेम मतलब डोमेन नेम ही है।
जो वेबसाइट होती है, टीएलडी टॉप लेवल
डोमेन होता है उसी की बात हो रही है। आईपी
एड्रेस मतलब आईपी एड्रेस ही है। तो यह
कॉन्सेप्ट सब वही है। बट यह उस तरीके से
ब्लॉकेज काम करती है नीचे से ऊपर की तरफ।
और उसी तरीके से पेन कॉज करती है अटैकर
को। मतलब एक ऐसा फ्रेमवर्क जो अटैकर को
पहले कम पेन देगा फिर ज्यादा ज्यादा फिर
बहुत मैक्सिमम पेन देगा एंड अटैकर की बैंड
बजाएगा। यह है पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन। आई होप कि
यू अंडरस्टुड टिल हियर। इसके बाद मैं
एक्सप्लेन करने वाला हूं एक-एक चीज को एंड
देन हम नेक्स्ट बढ़ेंगे। तो पहले मुझे
बताइए कि आर यू गेटिंग टिल हियर गाइस?
प्लीज मुझे बताइए कि आप सभी को यहां तक
समझ में आ गई है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके आप लेट ज्वाइन किए हैं तो आप बैक कर
लीजिए लाइव में भी ना वो जो क्या उसको
बोलते हैं यार जो भी होता है वह सीकर उसको
आप पीछे ले जाकर देख सकते हैं। ठीक है?
चलिए अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इसको
डील करते हैं। ये देख लीजिएगा ये इमेज को
देख लीजिएगा। अब आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। अब
यहां पे सिक्स लेयर्स ऑफ़ पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन
होता है बॉटम टू टॉप। जैसा मैंने डिस्कस
किया था। पिरा द पिरामिड इज़ अरेंज्ड फ्रॉम
द इज़िएस्ट इंडिकेटर्स। मतलब सबसे इजी
इंडिकेटर्स से स्टार्ट होता है टू ब्लॉक
एट द बॉटम। बॉटम पे ब्लॉक होता है टू द
हार्डेस्ट एंड मोस्ट पेनफुल एट द टॉप। और
हार्डेस्ट इंडिकेटर जो सबसे ऊपर तक होता
है। सबसे पहले मैंने बात की थी हैश वैल्यू
की। देखो हैश वैल्यू क्या है? व्हाट दे आर
यहां पे मैंने शॉर्ट में और बहुत ही अच्छे
से आपको समझाया है। बहुत ही टू द पॉइंट
समझाने की कोशिश करी है। आई होप कि आपका
क्लियर होता चलेगा। बाकी अगर आप चाहें तो
आप इन टॉपिक्स को अलग से बहुत डिटेल में
भी पढ़ सकते हैं। Google के थ्रू ईजीली
अवेलेबल है। बहुत सारे हमारे ही नेटवर्क
नेटवर्किंग का जो हमारा प्लेलिस्ट है उसी
में आपको ये सारी चीजें मिल जाएंगी। तो आप
उसको भी देख सकते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हैश वैल्यू क्या है? यूनिक
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक फिंगरप्रिंट्स। हैश
वैल्यू यूनिक क्रिप्टोग्राफिक
फिंगरप्रिंट्स होते हैं। जैसे कि MD5, एसए
वन, एसए 256। ठीक है? तो ये MD5 जो कि अ
मोस्टली यूज़ नहीं लिया जाता है। बिकॉज़ ऑफ
द ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक ससेस्टेबल टू द ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक एंड अलग-अलग अटैक्स से प्रोन
है ये। उसके बाद सिक्योर हैश एल्गोरिदम
आया वन फिर टू फिर थ्री। उसमें सबसे
पॉपुलर एसएचए 256 आया 256 बिट्स का। तो ये
सारी चीजें ये हैश वैल्यू होती है। साइन
टू स्पेसिफिक फाइल्स। हर फाइल्स की एक
यूनिक हैश वैल्यू होती है। जैसे आपके भी
कंप्यूटर में जो भी हैश वैल्यू आपके
फाइल्स हैं उन सबकी हैश वैल्यू अलग-अलग
होती है। बिल्कुल यूनिक होती है। ठीक है?
अगर दो ऑब्जेक्ट के हैश वैल्यूस सेम है
इसका मतलब है वो फिर सिक्योर नहीं है। दैट
इज़ नॉट सिक्योर। बस दैट्स इट। तो याद
रखिएगा आप जो बुक्स वगैरह या किसी भी किसी
भी तरह के ऑब्जेक्ट का हैश वैल्यू आप सेट
कर सकते हैं और हैश वैल्यू के थ्रू उसको
यूनिक आइडेंटिटी उसकी यूनिक तरीके से जो
है वो दे सकते हैं। हां तो मैंने कहां
बोला Myra मैंने करवाया था। मैंने तो बोला
Myra की वीडियो देखिएगा जो हमारे चैनल पे
अवेलेबल है। वही चीज़ है। आपको Myra वहां
से देखना है और उसको कंप्लीट करनी है। ठीक
है? म्रे वाली वीडियो सबको देखनी है। मैं
आपको बार-बार बोल रहा हूं क्योंकि वो बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। थोड़ा मेरी बात को
ध्यान रखिएगा प्लीज। एनालिस्ट एफर्ट टू
ब्लॉक एनालिस्ट ब्लॉक जो करता है तो उसका
एफर्ट क्या है? ट्रिवियल मतलब बहुत ही
लोअर लेवल का यह एक एफर्ट होता है। यू
ड्रॉप द एसए 256#श इंटू योर ईडीआर और
एसआईएम एंड एनी मैचिंग फाइल इज़ ब्लॉक्ड।
तो आप क्या करते हैं? उस एसए#श
को आप ईडीआर या एसआईएम में डाल देते हैं।
जो अटैकर का अटैकर अटैक किया अटैकर ने तो
वहां से जो हैश वैल्यू आपको मिली है कोई
मलशियस फाइल की हैश वैल्यू मिली आपको। अब
उस हैश वैल्यू को आपने ईडीआर या एसआईएम
में डाल दिया। अब वो मैचिंग उससे मैच जो
भी फाइल्स होंगी उनको ब्लॉक कर देगा आपका
इडीआर या एसआईएम। राइट? अब क्या होगा?
अटैकर अटैकर को कोई पेन होगा नन। क्या
अटैकर को कोई प्रॉब्लम होगी इससे? ना के
बराबर। क्यों? व्हाई? इफ एन अटैकर चेंजज़ अ
सिंगल बाइट। अगर अटैकर ने उस फाइल के अंदर
एक सिंगल बाइट भी चेंज किया, एक स्पेस डाल
दिया या एक कोई कैरेक्टर डाल दिया कुछ भी
रैंडम कैरेक्टर। द हैश चेंजेस कंप्लीटली।
पूरी की पूरी हैश चेंज हो जाएगी। तो फिर
क्या फायदा हुआ? मान लो उसने अपने मैलवेयर
में एक छोटा सा एक छोटा सा बाय कोड छोटा
सा एक कोड या छोटा सा एक चेंज कर दिया
जिससे उसके मैलवेअर पे कोई इंपैक्ट नहीं
पड़ा। कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ा। एंड उसका काम
वैसे ही हो रहा है। बट आप यहां पे हैश
वैल्यू के थ्रू ब्लॉक कर रहे हो तो नया
हैश वैल्यू जनरेट हो जाएगी। अब वो ब्लॉक
आपका किस काम का? ऐसे वो 10 बार चेंज कर
लेगा। आप कितनी बार ब्लॉक करोगे? राइट? तो
ये इसका कोई इंपैक्ट कुछ खास जो है वो
नहीं पड़ने वाला। अटैकर्स ऑटोमेट दिस
प्रोसेस यूजिंग कंपाइलर्स और पॉलीमॉर्फिक
कोड टू जनरेट थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़ यूनिक हैसेस पर
मिनट। अब अटैकर्स क्या करते हैं भैया? इस
चीज को ऑटोमेट कर देते हैं और वह क्या
करते हैं कि वह ऐसे ही छोटे-छोटे चेंजेस
करके हजारों हैश वैल्यू जनरेट करते रहते
हैं एक ही फाइल की जो मलिशियस फाइल है। बस
अब आप एज अ एज अ सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट एज अ
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट आप उसको ब्लॉक करते रहो।
यह कोई ज्यादा पेन कॉज नहीं करेगा अटैकर
को। अटैकर मजे में अपना काम करेगा। वो
अटैक कंटिन्यू रखेगा। सो एज अ एसओसी आपका
क्या टेक अवे होना चाहिए? क्या टेक अवे
है? हैशेस आर ग्रेट फॉर ब्लॉकिंग नोन
स्टैटिक थ्रेट्स बट यूज़लेस अगेंस्ट
सोफिस्टिकेटेड एक्टिव एडवर्सरीज। स्टैटिक
कोई थ्रेट है, कोई लो लेवल थ्रेट है, नोन
थ्रेट है नॉर्मल सा तो उसके लिए तो ठीक
है। उसको ब्लॉक करके ठीक है। बट अगर कोई
एक्टिव थ्रेट है, बहुत सोफिस्टिकेटेड है,
बहुत कोई बड़े लेवल पे कोई थ्रेट है, तो उस
पे यह वाला जो सीन है, वह काम नहीं करता
है। इसलिए नॉट मच ऑफ़ इफ़ेक्टिव। अब आते हैं
दूसरे हमारे चीज पे IP एड्रेस।
IP एड्रेस व्हाट दे आर द न्यूमेरिकल
नेटवर्क एड्रेस। हर डिवाइस जो नेटवर्क से
कनेक्टेड है।
राइट? उसका एक IPपी एड्रेस होता है।
न्यूमेरिकल
डिवाइस होता है। जो भी न्यूमेरिकल एड्रेस
होती है। जैसे इस तरीके की कुछ आई एड्रेस
होती है। यूज़्ड बाय अटैकर्स कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल सर्वर्स और प्रॉक्सी नेटवर्क्स।
तो अटैकर का जो कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर्स
होते हैं, C2 होते हैं, प्रॉक्सीस
नेटवर्क्स होते हैं, वो सब भी आपका जो है
वो पर्टिकुलरली IPपी एड्रेस उन सबके होते
हैं। दे आर आल्सो असाइंड IP एड्रेस।
एनालिस्ट एफर्ट्स टू ब्लॉक ईजी। अब
एनालिस्ट अगर आईपी को ब्लॉक कर दे अटैकर
के यह सोच के कि चलो उनका जो C2 सर्वर है
कमांड एंड कंट्रोल जहां से अटैकर सब कुछ
कंट्रोल कर रहा है। जिस जो डिवाइसेस जो
कंप्यूटर जोज सर्वर उसने कॉम्प्रोमाइज
किया है जो जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन कॉम्प्रोमाइज
किया है उसके पीसीस को कंप्यूटर को उसी C2
सर्वर से वो कंट्रोल करता है। तो उसका एक
आईपी है तो मान लो एज एसोसिएशन लिस्ट आपने
सोचा चलो आईपी ब्लॉक कर देते हैं। लेट्स
ब्लॉक द आईपी। तो इसका ये बहुत ही एक इजी
होता है। इंपैक्ट कुछ ज्यादा खास इंपैक्ट
नहीं होगा। यू ड्रॉप द आईपी इनू फायरवल
रूल और आईपी ब्लॉक लिस्ट। आपने फायरवॉल
रूल या आईपी ब्लॉक लिस्ट में आईपी को डाल
दिया। अब अटैकर को पेन क्या हुआ? अटैकर को
क्या दिक्कत हुई इससे? लगभग नेगलिजिबल। तो
छोटी सी ना के बराबर। ऐसा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] क्यों भाई?
आईपीस आर चीप एंड डिस्पोजेबल। बहुत चीप
होते हैं। डिस्पजेबल होते हैं। अटैकर्स
यूज़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड होम राउटर्स जिनको हम
बॉटनेट्स बोलते हैं। बॉट नेट्स बुलेट
प्रूफ होस्टिंग सर्विसेस। बुलेट प्रूफ
होस्टिंग सर्विज। यह कई लोगों को पता
होगा। डायनेमिक क्लाउड इंस्टेंसेस जैसे
एडब्ल्यू एजोर देन लेट देम स्पिन अप अ
न्यू आईपी एड्रेस इन सेकंड्स। अटैकर क्या
करते हैं? अलग-अलग आईपी चेंजेस करने के
तरीके आजमाते हैं। कॉम्प्रोमाइज
कंप्यूटरटर्स राउटर्स को यूज़ करेंगे।
जिनकी आईपी जो है वो अलग-अलग वो स्पिन ऑफ
करते रहते हैं। क्लाउड सर्विज को यूज़
करेंगे। इंस्टेंसेस को एक इंस्टेंस चालू
किया उससे काम किया। दूसरा इंस्टेंस चालू
किया उसकी एक अलग आईपी आएगी। तीसरा किया
उसकी एक अलग आईपी आएगी तो अलग आईपी
अलग-अलग चेंज होते रह जाएंगे। बुलेट प्रूफ
होस्टिंग सर्विज मतलब कि कुछ ऐसी होस्टिंग
सर्विज जो अटैक्स के लिए अपने आप को
अवेलेबल कराती है
कि आप यूज़ करो कि अगर मतलब कोई अटैकर है
अगर उन होस्टिंग सर्विज को यूज़ करता है तो
वो ब्लॉक नहीं करते हैं। वो बोलता है ठीक
है हम इसी के लिए बने ही हैं। आप मेरा
होस्टिंग सर्विस यूज़ करो जो अटैकवटक जो भी
इललीगल या या आपको जो भी ब्लैकहेड वाले
काम करने हैं कर लो।
बस सिंपल
सर मैं 11th 12th नहीं किए हूं तो मैंने
डायरेक्ट 10th के बाद डिप्लोमा इन
कंप्यूटर इंजीनियरिंग की है तो क्या मैं
एलिजिबल हूं साइबर सिक्योरिटी के लिए
डिप्लोमा किए हो तो बहुत कम चांसेस है
एलिजिबिलिटी के बहुत सारे कंपनीज़ एज अ
डिप्लोमा कैंडिडेट को रिजेक्ट कर देते हैं
एक्सेप्ट नहीं करते हैं तो वो कंपनी पे
डिपेंड करता है डिफ्रॉनिक्स जैसी कंपनी
इससे कोई मतलब नहीं रखती है डिफ्रॉनिक्स
जैसी कंपनी आप किसी भी तरह के डिग्री
होल्डर हैं उनको मौका देती है एंड बट अभी
बिकॉज़ हमारे यहां कोई ऐसी ओपनिंग नहीं है
हमारे यहां जब भी ओपनिंग होगी तो आपको
सबको पता चलता रहेगा हमारे सोशल हैंडल्स
से। तो इसलिए सोशल हैंडल्स पे जरूर एक्टिव
रहिएगा। बाकी मोस्टली कंपनी जो है
एक्सेप्ट नहीं करती है। राइट? चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो ये प्रॉब्लम
है। ये एक नॉर्मल नेगिजिबल इफेक्ट डालती
है IPपी एड्रेस। उसी तरीके से अब डोमेन
नेम से है। डोमेन नेम का आपको पता होगा
व्हाट दे आर अ ह्यूमन रीडेबल वेब
एड्रेसेस। जैसे कि Google का IPपी एड्रेस
था पहले मान लो तो अब उसका एक डोमेन नेम
होगा www.थing
समथिंग.com राइट? तो इस तरीके से ये डोमेन
नेम होता है। राइट? जैसे यह भी एक डोमेन
नेम है। mals lginate.com microsoft.com
yahoo.com, facebook.com सब डोमेन नेम है।
राइट? तो डोमेन नेम्स पॉइंटिंग टू अटैकर्स
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर। अब कोई डोमेन नेम है जो
अटैकर के इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर पे पॉइंट कर रहा
है। तो एनालिस्ट क्या करेगा? इसको ब्लॉक
करेगा। तो ये कैसा इंपैक्ट डालेगा? सिंपल
इंपैक्ट। बहुत ज्यादा इंपैक्ट नहीं
डालेगा। एवरीवन चैट में जो भी क्वेश्चन
पूछ रहे हैं, आई एम नॉट फोकसिंग ऑन द चैट
करेंटली। तो आपका आंसर नहीं कर पाऊंगा। तो
आप प्लीज फोकस कीजिए आप भी क्लास के ऊपर
में। लास्ट में हम उन क्वेश्चंस को डिस्कस
कर लेंगे क्लास के बाद।
यहां पे जब ब्लॉक करेगा अटैकर अटैकर के आप
डोमेन को ब्लॉक करेंगे तो ये भी एक सिंपल
पेन कॉज करेगा अटैकर को। ज्यादा पेन नहीं
देगा अटैकर को। अटैकर को ज्यादा इससे दुख
नहीं पहुंचने वाला है। ब्लॉक द डोमेन वाया
डीएनएस सिंक होलिंग। अब आप ब्लॉक कैसे
करेंगे? डोमेन को ब्लॉक करेंगे। डीएनएस
सिंक होलिंग और वेब प्रॉक्सी फ़्टर्स लाइक
स्प्लंक प्रॉक्सी क्वरी वी रोट अर्लियर।
तो आप स्प्लंक का ही आता है प्रॉक्सी
क्वरी मतलब स्प्लंक के अंदर भी आप डोमेनस
को ब्लॉक कर सकते हैं आराम से डीएनएस
ब्लॉकिंग कर सकते हैं। बट उससे कुछ खास
फायदा होने वाला नहीं है। पेन क्या कॉज
होगा? थोड़ा बहुत कॉज होगा। बहुत ज्यादा
कुछ कॉज नहीं होने वाला। हल्का पेन कॉज
होगा अटैकर को। व्हाई रजिस्टरिंग अ डोमेन
रिक्वायर्स बाइंग इट। सेटिंग अप डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड्स एंड वेटिंग फॉर प्रोपगेशन। यह
जरूरी होता है। डोमेन को अगर आप ओन करना
चाहते हैं तो आपको डोमेन को बाय करना
पड़ता है। उसका डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड सेटअप करना
पड़ता है और तब जाके जब डीएनएस प्रोपगेट
हो जाती है तब जाके आप डोमेन को यूज़ कर
पाते हैं। वाइल हार्डर दैन स्वाइपिंग एन
आईपी। IP स्वाइप करने से तो यह थोड़ा
हार्ड है क्योंकि IP तो तुरंत 2 मिनट में
स्वाइप हो जाती है। उसमें बहुत ज्यादा
रॉकेट साइंस नहीं है। अटैकर्स यूज़ द
डीजीएस डोमेन जनरेशन एल्गोरिदम टू रजिस्टर
100्स ऑफ़ बैकअप डोमेनस ऑटोमेटिकली। तो एक
कांसेप्ट होता है डीजीएस का। इसके बारे
में आप Google कर सकते हैं। नॉट वेरीेंट
एज़ एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट बट आपको थोड़ा पढ़ना
हो तो या यू कैन गो एंड यू कैन डेफिनेटली
चेक आउट। डीजीए डोमेन जनरेशन एल्गोरिदम
इसका यूज़ करके अटैकर्स क्या करते हैं ना
कि एक साथ बहुत सारे डोमेनस को रजिस्टर कर
लेते हैं और वो भी ऑटोमेटिकली ये एक बैकअप
डोमेन कहलाता है कि भैया चलो एक डोमेन गया
तो दूसरा हम यूज़ करेंगे तीसरा हम करेंगे
तो आखिर वो बैकअप डोमेन यूज़ कर पा रहे हैं
एंड आपने जो ब्लॉकेज किया है उनको थोड़ा
बहुत पेन दे रहा है थोड़ा काम बढ़ाया है बट
नॉट मच ऑफ द वर्क तो ये भी एक जो है यहां
पे काइंड काइंड ऑफ़ उतना ज्यादा पेन क्रिएट
नहीं करेगा। राइट? चैट में प्लीज आई एम
रिक्वेस्टिंग जो भी यहां पे चैट में मैसेज
पे मैसेज कर रहे हैं, इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट।
प्लीज डोंट मैसेज हियर एंड प्लीज इस पे
फोकस कीजिए। मैं आप लोगों को अभी फिलहाल
के लिए टाइम आउट में डाल रहा हूं। इसका
रीज़न बस इतना है। आप लोग स्पैम नहीं कर
रहे हैं। बट स्टिल रीज़न यह है क्योंकि आप
दूसरों को फिर डिस्टर्ब कर रहे हैं। तो,
इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू प्लीज डोंट डिस्टर्ब
एनीवन एंड प्लीज डोंट चैट इन द चैट बॉक्स।
अभी। जब मैं आगे यहां पे करा रहा हूं, तो
आप चैट बॉक्स में मत आइए। आप यहां पे फोकस
कीजिए। सो दैट आपका फोकस यहां पे रहे
मोस्टली। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए ये [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] था
डोमेन नेम का डोमेन नेम का इशू। अब आते
हैं नेक्स्ट चौथा जो है नेटवर्क या होस्ट
आर्टिफेक्ट्स।
नेटवर्क और होस्ट आर्टिफेक्ट्स। भैया ये
क्या है? क्या है? व्हाट दे आर?
द डिस्टिंक्ट ट्रेसेस लेफ्ट बिहाइंड ऑन द
नेटवर्क। अब कोई नेटवर्क पे अटैक जब करेगा
ना अटैकर तो उस पे कुछ ट्रेसेस भी रह जाते
हैं उसके। और एंड पॉइंट या कंप्यूटर सर्वर
इन सब पे भी बाय द अटैकर्स टूल द
डिस्टिंक्ट ट्रेसेस।
ठीक है? मतलब कि जैसे कोई अटैकर किसी
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर पे अटैक करता है।
किसी कंपनी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन पे अटैक करता है।
तो इससे क्या होता है? एक तो नेटवर्क के
अंदर कोई कुछ ट्रेसेस रह जाते हैं। कुछ
ट्रेसेस हो सकता है एंड पॉइंट्स पे रह
जाए। एंड पॉइंट्स का मतलब आपके लाइक जैसे
कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं, आपके सर्वर्स हैं। इन
सब के ऊपर भी ट्रेसेस राउटर्स वगैरह हो रह
सकते हैं। तो नेटवर्क आर्टि आर्टिफेक्ट्स
का मतलब क्या है? कस्टम यूजर एजेंट
स्ट्रिंग इन एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट्स, यूनिक
यूआरएल पाथ्स और स्पेसिफिक टीएलएस
सर्टिफिकेट हैस। तो क्या-क्या चीजें देखने
को मिल सकती है अटैकर की? तो कस्टम यूजर
एजेंट्स स्ट्रिंग्स मिल सकते हैं अटैकर्स
की। आपने अगर वेब हैकिंग पढ़ी होगी या
जानते होंगे तो जो हेडर होता है एचटीडीp
का हेडर उसमें यूजर एजेंट्स का एक फील्ड
होता है। तो उस यूजर एजेंट में जो हैकर है
उसके डिटेल्स हो सकते हैं। यूजर एजेंट्स
में जनरली ये होता है कि किस टाइप के
ब्राउज़र से और मशीन से जो अटैकर है वो
यूज़ कनेक्ट कर रहा है। मतलब जैसे Chrome
होगा तो Chrome का वहां पे आपको डिटेल पता
चलेगा। Firefox होगा तो Firefox के
डिटेल्स आपको पता चलेंगे। ऐसे यूजर एजेंस
के अंदर में यूजर के बारे में जो है
एग्जजेक्टली कहां से उसने कनेक्ट किया है।
किस तरह का क्लाइंट यूज़ कर रहा है वो पता
चलता है। यूनिक यूआरएल्स पाथ जो हो गए वो
होते हैं। तो यूनिक यूआरएल पाथ का मतलब कि
कुछ ऐसे यूनिक यूआरएल्स आपको देखने को मिल
सकते हैं उस पर्टिकुलर अह ट्रेसेस में जो
अटैकर तक आपको लेके जाए जो अटैकर से
कनेक्टेड है। ये सारी चीजें हो सकती है।
कुछ टीएलएस जो होती है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
सिक्योरिटी के जो एसएसएसएल के जगह पे अब
यूज़ होती है उसके सर्टिफिकेट हैसेस भी
देखने को मिल सकते हैं नेटवर्क ट्रेसेस के
अंदर में। अब होस्ट आर्टिफेक्ट्स की बात
करें होस्ट के अंदर यानी कि आपके कंप्यूटर
सर्वर के ऊपर क्या एड्रेसेस मिलते हैं।
स्पेसिफिक रजिस्ट्री की कोई रजिस्ट्री की
आपको अननोन रजिस्ट्री की मिल सकती है।
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर आपको उस पे ध्यान देना
पड़ेगा। फिर डिस्टिंक्ट फाइल नेम्स कुछ
ऐसे फाइल नेम्स देखने को मिल सकते हैं जो
आपको थोड़ा सा डिफरेंट अल्टर लगेगा। और
यूनिक म्यूटिस क्रिएटेड इन सिस्टम मेमोरी।
और सिस्टम मेमोरी के अंदर में कुछ यूनिक
चेंजज़ आपको या कुछ यूनिक अह आपको अह
एक्सटेंशंस या कुछ ऐसी चीजें मिल सकती हैं
जो सिस्टम मेमोरी में आपके क्रिएट हो गई
है। अब आपके मेमोरी के अंदर में सिस्टम
मेमोरी के अंदर जैसे कि मेमोरी बेस्ड जो
फाइललेस मेलवेस होते हैं जो मेमोरी के
अंदर अपने आपको हाइड करके रखते हैं। तो उस
टाइप की ट्रेसेस आपको मिल सकते हैं। तो ये
सारे होस्ट आर्टिफेक्ट्स में आते हैं। तो
दो तरह के होते हैं नेटवर्क आर्टिफेक्ट्स
एंड होस्ट आर्टिफेक्ट्स। यह दोनों चीजें
होती हैं फोर्थ लेयर में। अब एनालिस्ट
एफर्ट टू ब्लॉक। अब एनालिस्ट कैसे इसको
ब्लॉक करेगा? इसका इंपैक्ट क्या होगा? अगर
आप ब्लॉक कर देते हैं जो एज अ एनालिस्ट आप
ऐसे अटैक्स को इस पर्टिकुलर लेवल पे जब
ब्लॉक करते हैं तो क्या होगा?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये एक मॉडरेट
इंपैक्ट डालेगा अटैकर के ऊपर। अटैकर को
थोड़ा सा मॉडरेटली पीस ऑफ करेगा। थोड़ा
गुस्सा दिलाएगा हल्का सा। हल्का सा। अरे
यार ऐसे अरे शिट रिक्वायर्स कॉन्फ़िगरिंग
एनआईडीएस
नेटवर्क इंट्रोज़न डिटेक्शन सिस्टम्स लाइक
स्नॉट सरकाटा या surकाata बहुत लोग बोलते
हैं तो आप देख लीजिएगा सरसाटा कुछ भी बोल
लीजिए और यारा रूल्स ऑन द एंड पॉइंट
तो अब इस तरह के अटैक्स इस तरीके के लेवल
पे जब आप ब्लॉक करना चाहेंगे तो यहां पे
आपको जनरली फायर वाल का यूज़ करना पड़ेगा।
जनरली एक हार्डवेयर सॉरी हार्डवेयर फायरवल
बोल रहा हूं। सॉरी एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी। यहां
पे आपको आईडीएस जो है उसका यूज़ करना
पड़ेगा। इंट्रोसेंट डिटेक्शन सिस्टम्स जैसे
कि स्नॉट स्नॉट के बारे में शायद आपको पता
होगा। नहीं पता हो तो थोड़ा देख लीजिएगा।
वैसे SNT की वीडियो मैंने डाली हुई है।
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर YouTube चैनल जो हमारा
है उस पे आपको शायद स्नॉट की वीडियो मिल
जाएगी। राइट? अगर आपको स्लॉट के बारे में
जानना हो तो हमारी जो टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
YouTube चैनल है हमारी जो
ओल्ड इज गोल्ड चैनल है अ
दिस वन यहां पे आई थिंक आपको स्नॉट के
बारे में शायद मिल जाएगी। आई डोंट नो
अ
या दिस इज द दिस इज द वीडियो हाउ टू मेक
योर ओन फ्री आईडीएस या आईपीएस फॉर
प्रिवेंटिंग साइबर अटैक्स। इसमें मैंने
बेसिकली बताया है कि आप आईडीएस कैसे बना
सकते हैं अ इंट्रोस एंड डिटेक्शन सिस्टम
खुद का स्नॉट की हेल्प से। ठीक है? तो यह
वीडियो देख सकते हैं आप 5 साल पहले डली
हुई है। एंड यह चैनल जिनको नहीं पता हमारा
ही चैनल है। टेक्निकल नेविगेटर हम पहले
इसी को यूज़ करते थे। बट लगभग 400 से
ज्यादा साइबर सिक्योरिटी के एथिकल हैकिंग
के वीडियोस प्लस प्रैक्टिकल वीडियोस आपको
इसमें मिल जाएंगे। अगर कोई सीखना चाहे
प्रॉपर अच्छे से तो इस इस चैनल पे भी आके
ना बहुत कुछ अलग डिफरेंट चीजें आपको देखने
को मिल जाएगी। अभी भी अभी भी ये रिलेटेबल
है तो आप देख सकते हैं स्नॉट का तो आप देख
लीजिएगा यहां से राइट कई
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लोग जो जानते
होंगे वो पहले से उनको पता होगा इस चैनल
के बारे में राइट
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है चलिए लेट्स कम ऑन
तो यहां पे आपको इंट्रोसेंट डिटेक्शन
सिस्टम जो है सेटअप करना पड़ जाता है। अ
पेन कॉज टू अटैकर। अटैकर को क्या पेन आप
कॉज करेंगे? एनोइंग। बहुत ज्यादा परेशान
आप करेंगे इसके थ्रू। अटैकर की आप परेशानी
थोड़ा ज्यादा बढ़ा देंगे। क्यों? ऐसा
क्यों? द अटैकर हैज़ टू गो बैक टू देयर
सोर्स कोड मॉडिफाई हाउ देयर टूल
कम्युनिकेट्स और बिहेव्स ऑन द ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम रिकंपाइल इट एंड रीडप्लॉय इट। दिस
कॉस्ट देम टाइम एंड इंजीनियरिंग एफर्ट। अब
जब ऐसा काम आप करेंगे ना कि आप एक नेटवर्क
इंट्रोसन डिटेक्शन सिस्टम जो एनआईडीएस
कहलाता है आईडीएस का ही भाई है एनआईडीएस
तो उस लेवल पे जब आप यहां पे ब्लॉक कर
देते हैं ऐसे आईओसीस को तो यहां पे अब
अटैकर को आएगा गुस्सा वो बोलेगा अरे भाई
क्या कर रहे हो यार छोड़ ही नहीं रहे हो
पहले तुम छोटे लेवल पे करते हो अब यहां पे
तक पहुंच गए हो अब इस तरह की चीजें अब
तुमने कर दी है क्योंकि मेरे ट्रेसेस को
तुमने पकड़ के वहां पे ब्लॉक करी है तो अब
मुझे वापस से जाना पड़ेगा अपने सोर्स कोड
में सोर्स कोड जो मैंने कोड किया था
मैलवेयर को उसमें देखना पड़ेगा कि मैंने अ
सोर्स कोड में कुछ ऐसा क्या डाले कि
ट्रेसेस भी ना बच पाए।
एंड पूरी की पूरी कम्युनिकेशन एंड ये सब
जो चीजें हैं उसको चेंज करना पड़ेगा।
तरीका को चेंज करना पड़ेगा। बदलना पड़ेगा।
पूरी-पूरी बैंड बजा बज गई हमारी। मजा नहीं
आया यार ऐसे करके। तो ये सारी चीजें जो है
आपको बेसिकली ये इस पॉइंट पे समझ में आ गई
होगी। ये एनवाय कर देगा। परेशान कर देगा
हैकर को हमारे इस लेवल पे। ठीक है? उनको
पूरा सोर्स कोड चेंज करना पड़ेगा। उसके
बाद आते हैं लेवल फाइव टूल्स वाला। यह और
भी ज्यादा
टेंशन देने वाला है हमारे अटैकर भाई को।
तो यह क्या है? व्हाट दे आर द सॉफ्टवेयर।
यह जो सॉफ्टवेयर वो यूज़ कर रहे हैं। अब हम
उस पे अटैक करेंगे। मान लो यहां तक पांच
चौथे तक भी अटैकर अपने आप को बचाता आ गया।
मान लो चौथे तक भी अपने को बचाता गया।
उतना कुछ खास फर्क नहीं पड़ता। यहां तक हम
नहीं कुछ कर पाए। लेकिन हमने टूल्स को
डिटेक्ट कर लिया किसी तरीके से। मान लो
लेट्स सपोज। ठीक है? अब जब यहां पे आते
हैं तो सॉफ्टवेयर आती है, यूटिलिटीज आती
है। स्क्रिप्ट्स जो अटैकर यूज़ कर रहा है
अपने ऑब्जेक्टिव को पूरा करने के लिए।
जैसे मिमीड्स को यूज़ कर रहा है पासवर्ड
डंपिंग के लिए। कोबाल्ट स्ट्राइक को यूज़
किया जा रहा है। C2 हैंडलिंग नेविगेशन के
लिए। एंड पीएस पावर सेल एग्जिटिक को यूज
किया जा रहा है लेटरल मूवमेंट के लिए। तो
अब इस पर्टिकुलर लेवल पे आके सॉफ्टवेयर पे
हम टारगेट करने वाले हैं एज एन
एसोसिएलिस्ट। ये सारी चीजें एज एन एसोसिए
एनालिस्ट आप कर रहे हैं। अटैकर के अगेंस्ट
यही है पिरामिड ऑफ़ क्वीन। अटैकर को कितना
परेशान कर सकते हैं वो लेवल वो लेवल
दिखाता है। वो कनेक्शन दिखाता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एनालिस्ट
क्या एफर्ट ब्लॉक कैसे करेगा? तो ये
चैलेंजिंग है थोड़ा सा। दिस इज़ चैलेंजिंग।
रिक्वायर्स रोबस्ट इडिया रूल्स एंड बिहेवल
मॉनिटरिंग।
चैलेंजिंग है थोड़ा सा इसको ब्लॉक करना।
ठीक है? बट इसमें एक अलग से रोबस्ट इडीआर
जो रूल्स हैं अ उनको
यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट करना पड़ेगा। एंड
बिहेवल मॉनिटरिंग कि एक जो फाइल है, एक जो
स्क्रिप्ट है, एक जो टूल है वो किस तरीके
से बिहेव कर रही है सिस्टम के अंदर में?
क्या कुछ वियर्ड बिहेवियर है? कुछ अलग
तरीके से बिहेवियर है, कुछ अजीब बिहेवियर
है, कुछ मशियस टाइप बिहेवियर है। ये सब
सारी चीजें। तो अगर ऐसा कुछ है तो फिर
यहां पे फ्लैग होगा वो। ठीक है? अब देखो
पेन कॉज्ड टू अटैकर। अटैकर को क्या पेन
कॉज होगा? यह है चैलेंजिंग।
यह थोड़ा सा दिक्कत वाली बात है। अटैकर के
लिए दिक्कत वाली बात है। व्हाई? इफ यू
डिटेक्ट एंड ब्लॉक देयर प्राइमरी वेपंस
लाइक न्यूट्रलाइजिंग कोबाल्ट स्ट्राइक
बेकन सिग्नेचर्स अक्रॉस योर नेटवर्क। द
ट्रैकर कैन नॉट जस्ट ट्विक अ सेटिंग।
ठीक है? अभी यहां पे एक सेकंड मैं कुछ
लोगों को टाइम आउट डाल दूं। ये लोग समझते
नहीं है कि स्पैम नहीं करना। अभी आई एम
नॉट सीइंग गाइस द चैट अभी करेंटली। प्लीज
डोंट स्पैम। अदरवाइज द चैट्स विल बी
रिमूव्ड। सो प्लीज डोंट स्पैम। ऐसा क्यों?
क्योंकि जब आपने उनके टूल को ही
न्यूट्रलाइज कर दिया भाई तो बचा क्या उनके
पास? अब क्या करेंगे वो? दे मस्ट सोर्स
टेस्ट एंड मास्टर अ कंप्लीटली डिफरेंट टूल
सेट और राइट देयर ओन कस्टम सॉफ्टवेयर
फ्रॉम स्क्रैच। अब उनको एक दूसरा टूल
बनाना पड़ेगा। एक दूसरा टूल यूज़ करना
पड़ेगा एंड एक दूसरा मेथोडोलॉजी एक दूसरी
एक वे एक दूसरा तरीका इस्तेमाल करना
पड़ेगा। तब जाके जो है वो अब कुछ कर
पाएंगे। तो यह अटैकर के लिए थोड़ी सी
प्रॉब्लमेटिक हो गई है। अटैकर को अब
गुस्सा आ रहा है। बहुत ज्यादा गुस्सा आ
रहा है इस पर्टिकुलर लेवल पर जहां टूल्स
ही ब्लॉक हो गई। अब आते हैं लास्ट वाले पे
जो कि है टीटीपीस, टैिक्स, टेक्निक्स एंड
प्रोसीजर। यह द एपेक्स लेवल है। टॉप लेवल
है। क्या है यह? व्हाट दे आर? हाउ द
एडवर्सरी ऑपरेट्स फ्रॉम एंड टू एंड देयर
ऑपरेशनल हैबिट्स बिहेवियर्स स्ट्रेटजीस
टू गेन एक्सेस फॉललोड बाय एल्स एस मेमोरी
डंपिंग फॉर क्रेडेंशियल्स पावर शेल
एग्जीक्यूशन ये सब जो वो कर रहे हैं दीज़
आर कोडिफाइड इन द मथ्रे अटैक फ्रेमवर्क और
ये सारी चीजें मथ्रे अटैक फ्रेमवर्क में
भी कवर्ड है तो अब टीटीपीस जो है इन पे
अटैक होगा और जब इन पे अटैक होगा इसका
मतलब है टैक्टिक्स मतलब वो क्या किस तरह
के टैिक्स यूज करें? टेक्निक्स क्या
टेक्निक यूज़ करें? प्रोसीजर किस तरह का
प्रोसीजर यूज़ करें? हाउ दे आर ऑपरेटिंग तो
उस यहां पे व्हाट हाउ व्हाई? ये सबका जवाब
मिल रहा है। और आपने यह तो बैकबोन है यह
अटैक का। अगर आपने इसी को न्यूट्रलाइज कर
दिया तो अटैकर हैज़ लेफ्ट नथिंग टू डू नाउ।
अटैकर के पास अब कुछ भी नहीं है। अटैकर
कुछ नहीं बेचारा कर सकता है। वह अब बस
मुंह लटका के बैठ जाएगा और उसको सबसे
ज्यादा गुस्सा आएगा इसी टाइम पर कि अरे
भाई क्या हो गया यह क्योंकि उसके अटैक फेल
हो चुकी है। एनालिस्ट एफर्ट टू ब्लॉक
हार्ड थोड़ा हार्ड होगा एनालिस्ट के लिए
ब्लॉक करना इसको थोड़ा मुश्किल तो होगा।
रिक्वायर्स डीप हंटिंग। बहुत डीप हंटिंग
एंड डीएफआईआर का भी डिजिटल अह लाइक
फॉरेंसिक इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस का भी ज़रूरत
यहां पे आपको पड़ता है जनरली। बेसिकली इस
प्रोसेस तक आप एसओसी एल1 तो नहीं यहां
पहुंचेंगे। L1 विल नॉट रीच एट दिस लेवल।
L2 L3 का काम है। इंसिडेंट रेस्पोंडर
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक एक्सपर्ट्स जो है उनके
काम है ये। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कस्टम एनालिटिक्स एसआईएम कोरिलेशन एंड
मैच्योर एसओसी वर्क फ्लो। यहां एक प्रॉपर
एसोसिएटिव वर्क फ्लो बनाना पड़ेगा। एक डीप
हंटिंग करनी पड़ेगी। एक प्रॉपर डीप
फॉरेंसिक्स एनालिसिस करना पड़ेगा। तब जाके
कहीं इसको ब्लॉक किया जा सकता है। बट अगर
ब्लॉक हो जाता है तो अटैकर को बहुत तेज
पेन होगा। बहुत ज्यादा ऐसी पेन जो खत्म
नहीं होगी उसकी। ऐसा क्यों? टीटीपी
रिप्रेजेंट द अटैकर्स मसल मेमोरी एंड
स्किल सेट्स। अटैकर का सब कुछ यही टीटीपी
ही होता है भाई। याद रखिएगा। इफ यू
डिटेक्ट एंड ब्लॉक देयर कोर टेक्निक। फॉर
एग्ज़ांपल रेंडरिंग क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग
वाया एल्स एस इंपॉसिबल थ्रू ओएस हार्डिंग
एंड इडिया रोल्स यू फ़ोर्स द अटैकर टू
रीलर्न हाउ टू हैक दे मस्ट इन्वेंट
एंटायरली न्यू अटैक वेक्टर्स व्हिच
रिक्वायर्स मंथ्स ऑफ़ रिसर्च डेप डेवलपमेंट
एंड ट्रेनिंग। अब यहां अगर आप यहां तक
पहुंच गए तो आप अटैकर को यह फोर्स कर
देंगे कि वो यह सोच में पड़ जाए कि अब
मुझे हैकिंग नहीं आती है। अब अब मुझे वापस
से हैकिंग पढ़नी है। अब हैकिंग मेरे बस की
बात नहीं है क्योंकि मेरा तो टीटीp ही
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो चुका है। टीटीp पे ही
अटैक हो चुका है। टीटीp ही मेरा
न्यूट्रलाइज हो चुका है। एंड टीटीp इज द
बिगेस्ट
बिगेस्ट मसल मेमोरी एंड स्किल सेट्स हैकर
हैव एंड एडवाइ एंड एडवर्सरी हैव। यह
बिगेस्ट मसल मेमोरी होता है। इसके बिना
कोई भी बड़ी अटैक पॉसिबल नहीं है। अगर
इसको डिसरप्ट किया गया, इसको न्यूट्रलाइज
किया गया, किसी भी तरह के बड़े अटैक को
रोका जा सकता है। और इसी वजह से हमारे
अटैकर भाई बहुत गुस्से में आ जाते हैं और
उनको डाउट होने लगता है अपने स्किल सेट्स
पे। उनको लगता है कि भाई यह तो गड़बड़ हो
गई। जब कोई बड़े अटैक्स जो बड़े हैकिंग
अटैक्स होते हैं। उसमें जब एक अटैकर दूसरे
अटैकर को न्यूट्रलाइज कर रहा होता है।
आपने मूवीज वगैरह में देखा होगा। यू मस्ट
हैव सीन इन द मूवीज। साउथ की मूवीज में तो
बहुत ज्यादा दिखाते हैं। हिंदी मूवीज में
भी दिखाते हैं। अभी हमारी Jio Hotstar पे
वो सीरीज आई है। कौन सी पेट्रो करके जो आई
है वो आप देख सकते हैं।
दैट इज़ गुड। मतलब उस लेवल पे ठीक है।
अच्छा बताया है। नॉर्मल साइबर क्राइम्स
एंड ऑल इन सब चीज़ रिलेटेड बताया है। तो
वहां जो एक अटैकर दूसरे को जब न्यूट्रलाइज़
करता है तो बेसिकली वो उसके टीटीपीस तक
अगर पहुंच गया तो ईज़ली उसको ईली उसको हरा
देगा।
ईली उससे आगे निकल जाएगा। अगर नहीं पहुंच
पाया तो मुश्किल है। फिर ये कहानी है पूरी
आपके पिरामिड ऑफ पेन की। अब मुझे बता
दीजिए आप सभी लोग कि आपको
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां तक सभी को
समझ में आया या नहीं आया। सो लेट मी नो।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एवरीवन लेट मी नो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अ
डीड यू अंडरस्टैंड गाइस
एक बार बताइए फटाफट सभी को समझ में आ गया
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बताइए फिर हम आगे बढ़ते हैं। आई एम वेटिंग
फॉर एवरीवन रिस्पांस।
अरे [हंसी] यार एक एक बंदा पूछ रहा है सर
अटैक फिर कैसे पॉसिबल होता है जब एसओसी
ब्लॉक कर देते हैं। भाई सारे ब्लॉक थोड़ी
ना होते हैं। यही तो बात है ना। अटैकर भी
तो दिमाग लगा रहा है ना अलग-अलग तरह की
चीजें कि कैसे बाईपास करें उस चीज को। अब
सारे अटैक्स को तो ब्लॉक नहीं कर सकते
एसओसी वाले नहीं कर पाते हैं। राइट? सारे
अटैक्स को ब्लॉक नहीं कर पाते हैं।
मोस्टली कर देते हैं। बट सारे अटैक्स को
नहीं कर पाते हैं। बहुत सारे
सोफिस्टिकेटेड अटैक होंगे। उनको नहीं कर
पाते हैं। इस वजह से तो अटैक हो जाता है
ऑ्गेनाइजेशनंस के ऊपर। हां। अगर सारे अटैक
को ब्लॉक कर पाते फिर तो कोई अटैक ही नहीं
होती। यही तो यही तो बात है।
करेक्ट।
ठीक है? चलिए, सभी को समझ में आ गया। अब
आगे बढ़ते हैं। अब यहां पे एज अ एसओसी
आप इस पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन को कैसे यूज़ करेंगे?
हाउ एसओसी यूसेस दिस पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन? ये
भी एक सवाल है कि एज एन एसओसी आप कैसे
इसको यूज करेंगे। राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सबसे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पहले आपको
क्या करना है? ऑटोमेट द बॉटम। आपको बॉटम
जो नीचे वाली जो चीजें हैं ना जहां पे
अटैकर को ज्यादा पेन नहीं हो रही है। आप
जो चीजें कर रहे हैं बहुत इजी है आपके लिए
करना। डोमेन को ब्लॉक करना, आईपी को ब्लॉक
करना। राइट? को ब्लॉक करना। ये बहुत आसान
काम है। तो एज एन एसओसी आप इसको ऑटोमेट कर
दीजिए। एज एन एसोसिए एनालिस्ट जब आप कंपनी
में जॉब करने जाएंगे तो आपको इस पे ना
ह्यूमन एनालिस्ट को टाइम देने की जरूरत
नहीं है एज अ ह्यूमन आपको आपको इसको
ऑटोमेट कर देना है। नेवर स्पेंड ह्यूमन
एनालिस्ट टाइम मैनुअली लुकिंग अप md5 हैज़
और सिंगल आईपीस लेट योर एसआईएम एंड एसओएआर
प्लेटफॉर्म्स कंज्यूम थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
फीड्स टू ऑटो ब्लॉक द बॉटम थ्री लेयर्स।
तो नीचे के जो तीन लेयर्स हैं हमारे हैश
डोमेन एंड आईपी। इन तीनों को तो पहले
ऑटोमेट कर दिया जाएगा। ठीक है? यह काम आप
एसआईएम के थ्रू या एसओआर जो आप यूज़ कर रहे
हैं उसके थ्रू आप कर सकते हैं। ठीक है?
बहुत आसान हो गया। उसके बाद फोकस ह्यूमंस
ऑन द टॉप। अब जो
टिए टू और थ्री कैनालिस्ट हैं और जो थ्रेट
हंटर्स हैं जो डीएफआईआर टीम है डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक एंड इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन्डर जो होते
हैं उनको फोकस करना चाहिए देयर टाइम
मैपिंग बिहेवियर्स टू टीटीपीस।
टीटीपीस पर फोकस करना है। वही टीटीपी जो
मैंने आपको यहां बताया टैक्टिक्स
टेक्निक्स एंड प्रोसीजर इस पे फोकस करना
चाहिए एंड डिटेक्टिंग टूल्स इन द ईडीआर।
और ईडीआर का यूज़ करना चाहिए ताकि ईडीआर से
डिटेक्शन हो पाए। दैट इज़ हाउ यू ड्राइव अप
द कॉस्ट ऑफ एन अटैक एंड मेक योर
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन एन अन अपेलिंग टारगेट। और इस
तरीके से आप अपने ऑ्गेनाइजेशन को सेफ
गार्ड करते हैं। और जनरली मैंने आपको पहले
बोला ही था कि यह टीटीपीस वाली तक जो
प्रोसेस है जो ऊपर के प्रोसेससेस हैं या
टूल्स वाली प्रोसेससेस हैं जनरली यहां पे
एसओसी एनालिस्ट L1 का काम नहीं होता। ये
L2 L3 के ही लोग करते हैं। सीनियर जो आपके
होंगे वही करेंगे। राइट? तो यहां आपका L2
L3 ऑपरेट कर रहा होता है। दैट्स इट।
[हंसी]
ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हैप्पी
बर्थडे टू योर डॉटर एंड
यू गाइस शुड डेफिनेटली सेलिब्रेट द डॉटर्स
बर्थडे। हैप्पी बर्थडे टू योर डॉटर वंस
अगेन। चलिए अब यहां पे आते हैं। पिरामिड
ऑफ़ पेन को एक टेबल के थ्रू समझते हैं ताकि
एक ओवरव्यू रीकैप हो जाएगा। जिनको अभी तक
क्लियर नहीं था, वह इधर भी देख लीजिए। यह
रीकैप मैं करवा रहा हूं आपसे एक तरह से।
ठीक है? नीचे से ऊपर की तरफ जो है रिककैप
करते हैं। ठीक है? पिरामिड ऑफ़ पेन का ये
टेबल है। सबसे नीचे हैश वैल्यूज़ आते हैं
आपके। जैसे इस तरीके की हैश वैल्यू होती
है। कुछ इस तरीके के। इसमें डिटेक्शन
मैकेनिज्म क्या होता है? फाइल रेपुटेशन या
ब्लैक लिस्ट जो होती है इसमें डिटेक्शन
होती है। इस तरीके से डिटेक्शन ब्लैक
लिस्ट अगर है कोई हैश वैल्यू या फाइल की
रेपुटेशन देख के पता चलता है कि रेपुटेशन
क्या है? किस तरह की है? मलेशियस या कैसा
है। तो ये पता इससे चल जाती है। तो ये
डिटेक्शन मैकेनिज्म है। और अटैकर इंपैक्ट
क्या होता है ट्रेवियर बाइट चेंज रिसेट
हैश मतलब अटैकर के ऊपर कुछ ज्यादा अह जो
है वह इंपैक्ट नहीं होता है। बैठा हैकर
अपना हैश वैल्यू थोड़ा बहुत चेंज करेगा
थोड़ा बहुत उसके अंदर चेंज करेगा फाइल के
अंदर अपने स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर कोड के अंदर
दैट्स इट वो वापस से दूसरी हैश वैल्यू आ
जाएगी उसके बाद यहां पे है गुड इवनिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] गुड इवनिंग
नमस्ते आईपी एड्रेस कुछ इस तरीके से दिखती
है
फायरवल का जो यहां पे एक्सेस कंट्रोल
लिस्ट है उसमें आप डाल दीजिए आईपी
रेपुटेशन चेक करके पता लगाया जा सकता है
कि आईपी एड्रेस मलेशियास या क्या है
नेगलिजिबल इंपैक्ट है अटैकर के ऊपर में
ठीक है वो आईपी स्पुफिंग कर सकता है,
स्वाइपिंग कर सकता है। आराम से हो जाता
है। डोमेन नेम जैसे इस तरह की है डोमेन
नेम। अब यहां पे डीएनएस के अंदर चेंजेस
जो है वो नोटिस करके वेब प्रॉक्सी
फिल्टर्स को देख के डिटेक्ट किया जा सकता
है। ठीक है? यहां पे। एंड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे
थोड़ी सी मुश्किल है अटैकर के लिए क्योंकि
नया डोमेन रजिस्टर करना पड़ता है। हालांकि
उसको भी ऑटोमेट किया कर देते हैं वो लोग
और बहुत सारे डोमेनस को रजिस्टर कर लेते
हैं। तो यह भी बहुत ज़्यादा इंपैक्ट नहीं
करेगी अटैकर के ऊपर। अटैक के ऊपर में
हल्काफुल्का इंपैक्ट स्लाइट इंपैक्ट जो है
वो डालेगी। उसके बाद है नेटवर्क या होस्ट
आर्टिफेक्ट्स। तो यहां पे रजिस्ट्री कीज़
के थ्रू पता चल जाता है। यूजर रीजन के
थ्रू पता चल जाता है। यहां पे आईडीएस या
एनआईडीएस नेटवर्क इंट्रोसन डिटेक्शन
सिस्टम यूज़ किया जाता है उनको डिटेक्ट
करने के लिए। एंड ये थोड़ा सा दिक्कत है।
इसमें कोड में चेंजेस करने पड़ेंगे अटैकर
को। इन चीजों से वापस ये चीज़ें ना हो पाए,
वह डिटेक्ट ना हो पाए इसके लिए। तो, थोड़ा
सा एनवायॉ करता है थोड़ा सा गुस्सा दिलाता
है अटैकर को। देन आते हैं हमारे टूल्स। तो
कोबाल्ट स्ट्राइक मेकड जैसे टूल्स यूज
जैसे अगर यूज किए जा रहे हैं अटैकर की तरफ
से तो यहां पे जो एंटीवायरस या इडीआर
सिग्नेचर्स हैं उनके बेसिस पे डिटेक्ट
किया जाता है या मेमोरी स्कैन्स करके
डिटेक्ट किए जाते हैं। यह थोड़ा सा
मुश्किल खड़ा कर देता है। अच्छी खासी
मुश्किल बेसिकली अटैकर को नया टूल यूज़
करना पड़ जाता है क्योंकि उनका टूल
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो चुका है। उनका टूल जो है
डिटेक्ट हो चुका है। तो अब वो नया टूल
यूज़ करेंगे। तो इस पे अटैकर को एक्चुअली
गुस्सा आएगा। उसके बाद लास्ट सबसे टॉप पे
हेड है टीडीपी जिसमें कि जैसे क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग हो रही है एल्स एस की इस तरह की
कुछ या मेमोरी डंपिंग हो के कोई कुछ इस
तरीके के प्रोसेस हो रहे हैं तो उस केस
में डिटेक्ट मतलब ये सारी चीजें होती हैं
और ईडीआर से डिटेक्शन पॉसिबल है या mra
फ्रेमवर्क से मैपिंग करके ये पॉसिबल है कि
मथ्रे में जिस तरीके से सारी चीजें
लिस्टेड हैं स्टेप्स उसको मैप करो देखो कि
भाई इसमें से कुछ ऐसा चीज कुछ हो रहा है
क्या m्रे फ्रेमवर्क बेसिकली अटैकर के अह
हर बिहेवियर को मतलब मतलब अटैकर के
टीटीपीस को बेसिकली बताता है। ठीक है?
टेक्निक्स को बताता है। किस तरीके के
प्रोसीजर बताता है। राइट? टैक्टिक्स बताता
है कि कैसे वो काम कर रहा है। तो उसे मैप
करो। अगर वैसा कुछ है तो हां ये डिटेक्ट
होगा यहां पे कि हां भैया ये कुछ मलशियस
है। और ये फिर यहां पे दिक्कत है। अटैकर
को फोर्स कर देता है कि भाई जाइए फिर से
हैकिंग पढ़िए। फिर से सीखिए। फिर से
स्टार्ट कीजिए। ये पूरा का पूरा पिरामिड
ऑफ़ पेन आपका था। यहां पर पिरामिड ऑफ पेन
जो है हमारा खत्म होता है। यहां पर हमारा
यह टॉपिक समाप्त होता है। बट यहां पर यह
टॉपिक से सिर्फ नहीं है। यहां पे एक और
टॉपिक है हमारे पास यूनिफाइड किल चेन। दिस
इज़ यूनिफाइड किल चेन।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] अब
देखो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे यूनिफाइड किल चेन में अ क्या है?
आपने साइबर किल चेन तो पढ़ा है। राइट? अगर
मैं यहां पे सर्च करूं साइबर किल चेन अगर
कुछ इस तरीके से सर्च करूं। मैं इमेजज़ के
अंदर जाता हूं। ठीक है? एंड लेट्स सपोज
मैं विकपीडिया का ये एक इमेज उठा लेता
हूं। विकीडिया पे ही चलते हैं। ये एक इमेज
है। राइट? तो ये साइबर किल चेन कुछ इस
तरीके से आपको यहां पे दिखता है। राइट? 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 सात स्टेप्स आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिल जाते हैं। सात स्टेप्स होते
हैं साइबर किल चेन के। वीडियो ऑलरेडी है
चैनल पे। आप देख सकते हैं। वीडियो भी है
और मैंने भी लाइव एसओसी क्लास फाइव में
पूरी डिटेल में बताई हुई है। ठीक है?
इसमें सात है। बट ये जो यूनिफाइड किल चेन
होता है ना ये जो यूनिफाइड किल चेन है
आपका ये है।
इसमें
तीन मेन प्रोसेससेस होते हैं। फेजेस होते
हैं और 18
टैक्टिक्स होते हैं। 18 जो वहां पे सात थे
ना यहां 18 टैक्टिक्स हैं यूनिफाइड किल
चेन में। तो बेसिकली
जस्ट अ सेकंड एक सेकंड गाइस।
एक सेकंड जस्ट अ सेकंड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एक सेकंड
दीजिए मुझे आई एम डूइंग समथिंग
डूइंग समथिंग
[खांसने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके डन
ओके ठीक है चलिए डन ओके सो आई वास डूइंग
समथिंग अ अपन कहां पे थे अ हां हां
यूनिफाइड किल चेन पे तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वहां जो सात थे
अब यहां 18 हो चुके हैं। तो बेसिकली यहां
पे क्या किया गया है ना कि साइबर किलचेन
और मैतरे फ्रेमवर्क को मिला के एक सिंगल
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यूनिफाइड किलचेन बना दिया गया। यानी मैतरे
फ्रेमवर्क के भी कांसेप्ट को मिलाया गया।
उसके बाद साइबर किलचेन के कांसेप्ट को
मिलाया गया। दोनों को मिक्स किया गया और
एक तैयार किया गया यूनिफाइड किल चेन जो
बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग है और बहुत ही शानदार
है। अब यहां पे सारी चीजें एक ही जगह पे
है और यहां बताया जा रहा है गुड इवनिंग कि
कैसे
इस किल चेन का यूज़ अब किया जाता है और
किसी भी अटैक को डिटेक्ट करने में। किसी
भी अटैकर के अटैक को डिटेक्ट किया जा सकता
है यूनिफाइड किल चेन के थ्रू। चलिए
यूनिफाइड किल चेन यूकेसी इज एन एडवांस्ड
साइबर थ्रेट फ्रेमवर्क डिप्लॉयड बाय
सिक्योरिटी रिस्चर डेवलप्ड बाय सॉरी
सिक्योरिटी रिस्चर पॉल
पॉल पोल्स पॉल पोल्स इन्होंने डेवलप किया।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इट वास क्रिएटेड टू ओवरकम द लिमिटेशन ऑफ
ओल्डर मॉडल्स लाइक लॉक हिड मार्टिनस
क्लासिक साइबर किलचेन जो ओल्डर मॉडल थी
हमारी साइबर किल चेन उसके कुछ लिमिटेशंस
को ओवरकम करने के लिए व्हिच वाज़ टू लीनियर
एंड फोकस्ड हेवली ऑन पेरीमीटर डिफेंसेस
मतलब ये बहुत ही एक लीनियर टाइप थी ये
डिफेंस अह फ्रेमवर्क और पेरीमीटर डिफेंस
थी मतलब बेसिकली मतलब कि जैसे घर के चारों
तरफ बाउंड्री होती है ना तो बाउंड्री
बाउंड्री पे तैनाती हो गई। बाउंड्री
बाउंड्री पे डिफेंस एंड बाउंड्री बाउंड्री
पे सिक्योरिटी लगा दी। अंदर का कुछ
सिक्योरिटी का कुछ पता ही नहीं है। मतलब
बाउंड्री अगर कोई क्रॉस करके आ गया गलती
से तो अंदर कुछ भी कर सकता है। इस
लिमिटेशन को खत्म कर दिया गया यहां पे। अब
अगर बाउंड्री वाली सिक्योरिटी ब्रीच करके
कोई घर में घुसता भी है तो घर के अंदर भी
सिक्योरिटी होगी। बस दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? चलिए। तो यहां पे एंड देखिए जो भी
क्वेश्चंस आप लोग कर रहे हैं आप लोग जितने
भी क्वेश्चंस कर रहे हैं इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट
कि उनके आंसर मैं अभी करंट क्लास में नहीं
दे पाऊंगा। इसका रीज़न मैं बताता हूं आपको।
कई लोग जो वीडियो के रिकॉर्डिंग देखते हैं
ना उनको डिस्टरबेंस होती है। राइट? वो फिर
क्या होते हैं? वो नॉन मतलब रिलेटेबल
चीजों के साथ जुड़ जाते हैं। और फिर तो हम
इसको लास्ट में रखेंगे। आपके जो भी
क्वेश्चंस हैं मैं उसका आंसर कर दूंगा।
प्लीज वेट टिल द एंड। राइट? ठीक है?
एंड कॉम्प्लीमेंट द मत्रे अटैक फ्रेमवर्क।
और माइथ्रे अटैक फ्रेमवर्क को
कॉम्प्लीमेंट करता है। कॉम्प्लीमेंट मतलब
मत अटैक फ्रेमवर्क को सपोर्ट करता है। मत
अटैक फ्रेमवर्क को इट सपोर्ट्स यूनिफाइड
किलचे। चलिए कैसे देखते हैं। द यूनिफाइड
किलचे प्रोवाइड्स अ कॉम्प्रिहेंसिव
सीक्वेंशियल मॉडल ऑफ मॉडर्न साइबर अटैक्स।
ये मॉडर्न साइबर अटैक्स को मैप करता है कि
मॉडर्न अभी जो करंट में जितने साइबर
अटैक्स जिसज तरह के जितने लेवल पर होते
हैं उनको ये कॉम्प्लीमेंट करता है। उनको
यह पूरा मैप करता है। इट एस्टैब्लिशस एन
एंड टू एंड फ्रेमवर्क। ये एक एंड टू एंड
फ्रेमवर्क एस्टैब्लिश करता है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कंसिस्टिंग ऑफ 18 टैक्टिक्स ग्रुप्ड इनू
थ्री मेन ऑपरेशनल फेसेस। 18 टैक्टिक्स में
डिवाइड किया गया है और उन सबको तीन मेजर
ऑपरेशनल फेसेस में डिवाइड किया गया है।
मतलब तीन फेजेस के अंदर वो सारे 18 के 18
टैक्टिक्स इंक्लूडेड है। कैसे देखेंगे हम
जो पहले के मॉडल्स थे हमारे फ्रेमवर्स थे
वो कैसे काम करते थे? इनफेक्ट एग्जीक्यूट
एक्सप्ललोड।
ठीक है? मतलब अटैक्स को इसी तरीके से
अ्यूम करते थे कि अटैकर क्या करेंगे कि
किसी भी सिस्टम को इनफेक्ट करेंगे। सबसे
पहले उसके बाद एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे अपने जो
भी टूल्स पेलोड्स वगैरह हैं और एक्सप्ललोड
कर देंगे और डम
काम हो जाएगा मतलब उनका अपना चलता रहेगा
रिवर्स कनेक्शन एंड ऑल सब कुछ ये पहले के
फ्रेमस थे। मॉडर्न एपीटीज जो आजकल के
एडवांस्ड पर्सिस्टेंट थ्रेट्स हैं। एडवांस
पर्सिस्टेंट थ्रेट्स के बारे में मैंने
बताया हुआ है। ऐसी कोई थ्रेट जो बहुत टाइम
से किसी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन किसी सर्वर के अंदर
बैठा हुआ है चुपचाप उस समय का इंतजार कर
रहा है। एक सही समय का इंतजार कर रहा है।
ताकि वो उस चीज को एग्जीक्यूट कर सके।
बड़े लेवल पर नेटवर्क के अंदर छिप चुका
है, बैठ चुका है जाके। ऐसे चुपचाप बैठा
हुआ है। जैसे आपने देखा होगा अ आई थिंक
अवेंजर्स
सीरीज का ही
है। अवेंजर्स का ही है। जब आपने देखा होगा
वो जो बटिस्टा होता है जब ये दोनों बात कर
रहे होते हैं हमारे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गार्डियन ऑफ़ गैलेक्सी वाले एक्टर
एक्ट्रेसेस तो चुपचाप खड़ा होता है। वो
बोलता है कि मैं तो यहीं पे था खड़ा।
चुपचाप बैठा हुआ। चुपचाप खड़ा था। मुझे
लगा आपने देखा नहीं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो उस तरीके से जो मॉडर्न एपीडीज होते हैं
जो एडवांस पर्सेशन थ्रेट्स होते हैं वो
चुपचाप नेटवर्क के अंदर बैठे रहते हैं
लॉन्ग टाइम के लिए। ठीक है? सही समय का
इंतजार करते हैं। एंड रेंस देयर गैंग्स
डोंट वर्क लाइक दैट। उस तरीके से काम नहीं
करते। क्यों? दे गेट इनसाइड हाइड फॉर
मंथ्स। जैसा मैंने बताया मंथ्स तक वो अपने
आप को छिपा के रखते हैं। पाइवोट अक्रॉस
डज़ंस ऑफ़ मशीनंस और अंदर ही अंदर एक मशीन
से दूसरे मशीन, दूसरे मशीन से तीसरे मशीन
में घुसते रहते हैं। लैटरल मूवमेंट करते
रहते हैं। एस्केलेट द प्रिविलेजेस। सब पे
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करते रहते हैं। सब पे
अपनी नॉर्मल यूजर को सुपर यूजर या रूट
यूजर या एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर बनाते रहते हैं।
एंड एस्टैब्लिश मल्टीपल फॉलबैक
कम्युनिकेशन एंड फॉलबैक कम्युनिकेशंस
इस्टैब्लिश करते रहते हैं कि भ आप वहां से
कैसे कम्युनिकेट हम करेंगे। वहां से कैसे
कम्युनिकेट करेंगे ये सारी चीज़। द यूकेसी
मॉडल्स दिस साइक्लिकल जो आपका यूनिफाइड
किल चेन है इसको एज अ साइक्लिकल मॉडल करता
है। नॉन लीनियर बिहेवियर एक्यूरेटली
लीनियर नहीं करता है कि बस इनफेक्ट किया
एग्जीक्यूट किया एक्सप्लोर वैसे मैप नहीं
करता है। गिविंग एसोसिए एनालिस्ट अ
कंप्लीट मैप ऑफ एन अटैकर्स जर्नी और इस
तरीके से वह अटैकर्स के जर्नी को एक
कंप्लीट मैप देता है। कंप्लीट मैप
प्रोवाइड करता है। इसी तरीके से
यह आपकी है यूनिफाइड किल चेन। अब इसको हम
समझेंगे एग्जैक्टली क्या कैसे होता है
उसको हम देखेंगे। कुछ इस तरीके का यह
इंटरफेस आपको मैंने दिखा रहा है। दिखाया
यूनिफाइड किल चेन का एंड टू एंड अटैक लाइफ
साइकिल का। जैसा मैंने बोला था कि टोटल 18
स्टेप्स 18 स्टेजेस होते हैं। तीन मेजर अह
फेजेस में डिवाइड होते हैं। तो एक फेज
होता है इनफिल्ट्रेशन का।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
दूसरा होता है प्रोपगेशन का। तीसरा होता
है एक्शन का। इनफिल्ट्रेशन में सबसे
ज्यादा फेस यहां पे अंदर में सब फेजेस
होते हैं। यहां पे आठ होते हैं यहां पे।
उसके बाद प्रोपगेशन। इनफिल्ट्रेशन गेनिंग
ऑफ़ फुटहोल्ड। अटैकर कैसे फुटहोल्ड गेन
करता है, घुसता है स्टार्टिंग में। उसके
बाद कैसे अपनी रीच को बढ़ाता है और कैसे
फिर जो है अपने ऑब्जेक्टिव्स को अचीव करता
है अटैकर। ये पूरा डिटेल बताता है। अब आप
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखेंगे इसको।
तो एस्टैब्लिशिंग सीक्रेट पर्सिस्टेंट
कंट्रोल ऑन अ सिंगल होस्ट। सो
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
पोस्ट देख के दिल घबरा गया। टेंशन मत लो।
अभी मैं अभी एक्सप्लेन करूंगा। ठीक है?
सबसे पहले वो एक पर्सिस्टेंट कंट्रोल एक
सिंगल होस्ट पे अचीव करता है अटैकर। यह
कैसे आपका करता है? सबसे पहले रिकॉनसेंस
यहां पे यूज़ होती है। देन वेपनाइजेशन यूज़
होता है। ठीक है? यहां पर थर्ड यहां पर
आपका
थर्ड स्टेप यूज होता है। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
वगैरह यूज किए जाते हैं। ठीक है? उसके बाद
यहां पे फोर्थ स्टेप आती है। फिफ्थ स्टेप
आती है, सिक्स्थ आती है, सेवंथ आती है,
एट्थ आती है। तो ये सारे आपको दिख रहे
होंगे यहां पे। ये जो स्टेप्स हैं, ये
सारे स्टेप्स यहां पे यूज़ में होते हैं।
ठीक है? रिकॉग्निशनेंस हो गया, वेपनाइजेशन
हो गया, सोशल इंजीनियरिंग हो गई आपका। देन
आपका
एक्सप्लॉयटेशन हो गया, देन पर्सिस्टेंस
आपकी हो गई। देन डिफेंस इवेशन हो गया। फिर
कमांड एंड कंट्रोल हो गया। ये सारी चीजें
इसका पार्ट है। ठीक है? रिकॉग्निसेंस से
शुरू होती है वेपनाइजेशन करते हुए यहां
पे। फिर अह
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करते हुए। फिर यहां पर
फायरवल इवेशन वगैरह यह सब भी करते हैं।
एक्सप्लइटेशन करते हैं। पर्सिस्टेंट करते
हैं। तो ये पूरा का पूरा एक स्टेप फॉल हो
गया। मतलब आप अगर देखोगे मत्री फेम को तो
उसमें इसमें से बहुत सारी जो चीजें हैं
आपको देखने को मिलेगी। ठीक है? बहुत सारी
चीजें आपको साइबर किल चेन में भी देखने को
मिलेंगी। तो ये स्टेप्स प्रोसेस पहले वो
करता है जहां पे लास्ट में कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल C2 कम्युनिकेशन बेक ऑन यहां पे C2
सर्वर जो है वो सेटअप कर देता है लास्ट
में आपका कमांड एंड कंट्रोल दैट्स इट। ठीक
है? तो अब ये सारे ऑप्शंस अभी हम डील करने
वाले हैं एक-एक करके। टेंशन नहीं लेना
आपको। मैं डिटेल में भी बताऊंगा। अभी मैं
बस ओवरव्यू आपको दे रहा हूं। उसके बाद ये
आता है दूसरे फेज पे। जहां पे दूसरे फेज
पे क्या होता है भैया? दूसरे फेजेस पे
यहां पे आपके होते हैं
डिवोटिंग।
एक पाइवोटिंग मतलब एक नेटवर्क से दूसरे
नेटवर्क में घुसना। एक नेटवर्क से दूसरे
नेटवर्क में जंप करना। लेटरल मूवमेंट
जिसको बोलते हैं। ठीक है? डिस्कवरी करते
हैं। पाइवोट करते हैं, एग्जीक्यूशन करते
हैं। प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करते हैं।
क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस करते हैं। प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करते हैं। रिमोट एग्जीक्यूशन
करते हैं। लैटरल मूवमेंट करते हैं। ये
सारी चीजें होती हैं। ठीक है? तो ये पूरी
अ एक जो पूरे प्रोसेससेस है, स्टेप्स हैं
वो आती है प्रोपगेशन में कि वो किस तरीके
से अपने आप को मूव कर रहे हैं। मतलब कि
पाइवोट कर रहे हैं। बेसिकली डिस्कवरी
डिस्कवरी कर रहे हैं डिवाइसेस को। वो
पाइवर कर रहे हैं। एग्जीक्यूशन कर रहे
हैं। लाइक स्क्रिप्ट्स वगैरह को
एग्जीक्यूट कर रहे हैं। प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेट कर रहे हैं। रिमोट कोड
एग्जीक्यूशंस कर रहे हैं। क्रेडेंशियल्स
को एक्सेस कर रहे हैं और लेटरल मूवमेंट कर
रहे हैं। एक डिवाइस से दूसरे डिवाइस में
जंप कर रहे हैं। फिर आती है तीसरी फेज
इनकी जहां पे एक्शन जो वो क्या करते हैं?
एग्जीक्यूटिंग द अटैकर्स मास्टर इंटेंट
एंड फुलफिलिंग देयर गोल्स। अब यहां पे
अटैकर अपना मास्टर प्लान एग्जीक्यूट करता
है। क्या करता है? कलेक्शन। वो कलेक्ट
करता है। डेटाज़ वगैरह कलेक्ट करता है।
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन डेटाज़ को अपलोड करता है।
बाहर के सर्वर पे भेजता है। इंपैक्ट
डिस्कस इंक्रिप्ट वगैरह करता है। बैकअप से
डिलीट करता है। रैंसमवेयर अटैक्स में ऐसे
ही होते हैं। फायरवल इवेशन वगैरह यहां पे
सारी चीजें होती हैं। ये सब भी एंड देन जो
है ऑब्जेक्टिव्स यानी कि जो फाइनेंशियल
एक्सट्रैक्शन हो गया, स्टेट स्पैनिज़ हो
गई, रेपुटेशन हो गया। जिस तरह का अटैक हुआ
अगर स्टेट स्पों्सर्ड साइबर अटैक है तो उस
तरीके से हो गया या फाइनेंसियल डाटा
चुराना है तो उस तरीके से हो गया। ये सारी
चीजें यहां पे होती है। तो लास्ट में ये
पूरा का पूरा एक्शन होता है। तो ये पूरा
18 फेज जो है आपको दिख रहा था। तीन यहां
पे मेजर फेजेस के अंदर 18 टैक्टिक्स यहां
पे। अब इनको हम एक-एक करके
फिलहाल [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डील करने
वाले हैं। एक-एक करके मैं आपको समझाऊंगा।
पहले हम फेज वन को समझते हैं। बहुत इजी वे
में मैं आपको समझाऊंगा। ठीक है?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] फेज वन में है
इनफिल्ट्रेशन। गेनिंग ऑफ फुट होल्ड इन दिस
फेज द अटैकर इज आउटसाइड और ऑन द एज ऑफ द
नेटवर्क। यहां पर अभी अटैकर नेटवर्क से
बाहर रहता है। या नेटवर्क पे ही अभी बैठा
है। नेटवर्क के एकदम एज पे है। देयर गोल
इज़ टू गेट इनसाइड अ सिंगल होस्ट। उनका एक
गोल होता है सिंपल सा कि एक होस्ट के अंदर
एक कंप्यूटर के अंदर घुस जाओ। उसके बाद
तबाही मचाते रहो। एंड एस्टैब्लिश
पर्सिस्टेंस क्वाइट कंट्रोल। और एक
कंप्यूटर के अंदर घुस के एक पर्सिस्टेंट
कंट्रोल सेटअप करो। एक अह क्वाइट कंट्रोल
एक अच्छा कंट्रोल बना लो एक सिस्टम के
अंदर। बाद में तो हम और चीजें देख लेंगे।
यह पहला फज़ वन का गोल होता है। फज़ वन में
अब क्या-क्या वो करते हैं? हम उनको देखते
हैं। बट जस्ट अ सेकंड।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
क्लास आपकी अभी चलेगी आधे घंटे कम से कम।
हाफ एन आवर अ मैक्सिमम।
अब यहां पर आठ चीजें आती हैं जो मैंने
पहले ही बोला रेनसेंस यहां मेरे को कलर
चेंज करना नहीं यार ब्लू रेकोसेंस
पहला रेसेंस वेपनाइजेशन डिलीवरी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग एक्सप्लइटेशन पर्सिस्टेंस
डिफेंसिव कमांड एंड जैसा मैंने पहले बताया
चैट के थ्रू वही चीज़ है रेकोसेंस में क्या
होता है गैदरिंग Intel ऑन टारगेट
एंप्लाइजज़ डोमेनस एंड ओपन पोर्ट्स इसमें
अटैकर क्या करता है Intel गैदर करता है
टारगेट एम्प्लाइजज़ के ऊपर, डोमेनस के ऊपर,
ओपन पोर्ट्स के ऊपर। अब जब तक इंटेल नहीं
होगी, जब तक हमारे पास डिटेल प्रॉपर डिटेल
नहीं होगी किसी टारगेट के बारे में, इनेशन
गैदरिंग अगर नहीं करते हैं, तब तक एक
सक्सेसफुल अटैक पॉसिबल है ही नहीं। इट्स
नॉट पॉसिबल। राइट? तो ये इनेशन गैदरिंग
करते हैं। ओसिंट यहां पे रियल वर्ल्ड
एसओसी एग्जांपल क्या है? ओसंट
हार्वेस्टिंग, शोडान क्वरीज़ Lindin
स्क्रैपिंग। तो यहां पर एज एन एसओसी आपको
क्या देखने को मिल सकता है? यहां पर
ओसिएंट हार्वेस्टिंग हो रही है। ओसेंट हो
रही है। ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस हो रही है।
शोडान के क्वरीज़ वगैरह रन किए जा रहे हैं।
Lindin का मैपिंग किया जा रहा है। Lindin
Lindin का। Lindin स्क्रैपिंग करके Lindin
के यूज़ करके Lindin का वहां से डिटेल्स
निकाला जा रहा है। ये सारी चीज़ होती है।
उसके बाद आती है वेपनाइजेशन। क्रिएटिंग द
पेलोड कंबाइंड विथ एन एक्सप्लइट और लेर।
मतलब कि एक पेलोड तैयार करना। एक्सप्लइट
मतलब एक एक्सप्लइट का यूज़ करो। कोई
एक्सप्लइट है उसको यूज़ करो। पेलोड बनाओ।
अपना अपना हथियार असली हथियार। एंबेडिंग अ
मलिशियस माइक्रो इनसाइड अ वर्ड
डॉक्यूमेंट। एज एन एसओसी आपको अ क्या
देखने को मिल सकता है कि एक माइक्रो
मलेशियस माइक्रो जो है वो आपको एक वर्ड
डॉक्यूमेंट में देखने को मिल सकता है जो
अटैकर की तरफ से अह उसमें डाला गया है।
तो, यह एज़ एन एसओसी आपको देखने को मिल
सकता है। डिलीवरी में क्या करते हैं वह?
ट्रांसमिटिंग द पेलोड टू विक्टिम। अब वो
उस पेट को विक्टिम को ट्रांसमिट करते हैं।
डिलीवरी में यही होता है। अब एज अ एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट आपको क्या देखने को मिलेंगे?
फिशिंग ईमेल्स देखने को मिलेंगे। फिशिंग
ईमेल्स आपके पास आएंगे। ड्राइव बाय
डाउनलोड्स आपको देखने को मिलेंगे और
एक्सपोज्ड आरडीपी पोर्ट्स मिलेंगे। तो कुछ
एक्सपोज आरडीबी पोर्ट्स हो गए। फिशिंग
ईमेल्स आ गए। ड्राइव बाय डाउनलोड्स फ़
डाउनलोड्स या ईमेल डाउनलोड्स या किसी भी
तरह के डाउनलोड्स जो होते हैं जो आपको फ़
डाउनलोड करवा रहे हैं वो देखने को आपको
मिलेगा। देन आती है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग जो
सबसे बड़ा यहां पर एक पॉइंट है।
मैनपुलेटिंग ह्यूमंस टू एग्जीक्यूट एन
एक्शन। ह्यूमन इमोशंस को मैनपुलेट करना टू
एग्जीक्यूट द एक्शन। अब ह्यूमंस को टारगेट
करना जो एंप्लाइजज़ की डिटेल्स निकाली थी
जो टारगेट की डिटेल्स निकाली थी उनप अब
अपना सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का टैक्टिक लगाना
जिसका बहुत मुश्किल है तोड़ कोई बट वो लगा
के उनसे डिटेल्स निकलवाना। प्री
टेक्स्टिंग कॉल्स और अर्जेंट एमएफए प्र्ट
स्पैमिंग। अब कोई एक
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] पहले से
प्रीडफाइंड कॉल आ रही है किसी एंप्लई के
पास से एंप्लई के पास या
एमएफए मल्टीफैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन का एकदम
अर्जेंटली आ रहा है कि भैया अरे
मल्टीफैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन देना ये एक कोड आया
होगा जल्दी से पूरी कंपनी के ऊपर अटैक हुआ
है जल्दी दो इस तरह की कुछ अर्जेंसी
क्रिएट करना तो ये सारी चीजें जो होती है
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में उसके बाद आती है
एक्सप्लइटेशन इसमें क्या होती है
ट्रिगरिंग सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटीज़ टू
एग्जीक्यूट द कोड अब जो एक्सप्लइट बनी है
वह एक्सप्लइट जिस भी पर्टिकुलर अगर
वनेबिलिटी को लेके बनी हुई है या जिस भी
वनेबिलिटी के अगेंस्ट यूज़ किया जा रहा है
तो वो जो सॉफ्टवेयर अगर अवेलेबल है उस
सिस्टम के अंदर में जैसे मान लो कि मेरे
पास एक वनरेबल Microsoft Office का पैकेज
है या वर्ड वर्ड यूज़ कर रहा हूं मैं
वनरेबल वर्ड तो माइक्रो अटैक हो रहा है
मान लो तो वहां पे उनको टारगेट किया जाता
है ताकि अटैक को सक्सेसफुल बनाया जा सके।
तो अब यहां पे उन सॉफ्टवेयर्स को वो
मलेशिया सॉफ्टवेयर को ट एग्जीक्यूट किया
जाता है। एसओसी की तरह क्या आपको देखने को
मिलेगा? एक्सप्लइटिंग अ ज़ीरो डे इन एन
अनपैच्ड वेब प्रॉक्सी। अभी एक ज़ीरो डे को
एक्सप्लइट किया जा रहा है। आपको यह देखने
को मिलेगा कि अरे यार एक ज़ीरो डे को भी
एक्सप्लइट किया जा रहा है। यहां पे कुछ
गड़बड़ है। पर्सिस्टेंस उसके बाद ऑप्शन आता
है। पर्सिस्टेंस फेज आती है। इसमें क्या
होता है? इंश्योरिंग एक्सेस सर्वाइव
सिस्टम रिवोट्स और पासवर्ड रिसेट्स। मतलब
अब यह पर्सिस्टेंट मोड आता है। इसका फेज
जो है सिक्स पे कि मतलब कोई भी अटैकर जब
अटैक करेगा यार तो ऐसे ही थोड़ी ना छोड़
देगा। अटैक करेगा तो पर्सिस्टेंस लेने की
कोशिश करता है वो ताकि अगर कोई सिस्टम
रिबूूट भी कर दे अब मान लो हड़बड़ी में
जल्दी-जल्दी में कोई सोचे कि यार रिबूूट
कर लो सिस्टम को यार अटैक हो गया है या
पासवर्ड रिसेट कर दो यार अटैक हुआ है तो
वो पर्सिस्टेंस अपने आप को इस्टैब्लिश
करता है ताकि सिस्टम रिबूट हो या पासवर्ड
रिसेट हो उससे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है।
स्टिल दे विल हैव द एक्सेस ऑफ़ द सिस्टम।
अटैकर्स को एक्सेस रहेगा। राइटिंग
रजिस्ट्री ऑटो रन कीज़ और क्रिएटिंग
शेड्यूल टास्क यह काम आपको देखने को मिल
सकते हैं कि रजिस्ट्री के अंदर में ऑटो रन
की कीज़ है। शेड्यूल टास्क जो है वह
यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है। शेड्यूल
टास्क के अंदर में चीजें हैं। तो मतलब
अटैकर जो है वो सारे कुछ मैनेज करके चल
रहा है अपना। उसके बाद आती है डिफेंस
इवेशन। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डिसेबलिंग और बाईपासिंग सिक्योरिटी टूल्स।
अब जैसे अटाका ने अगर सिक्योरिटी टूल्स को
डिफेंस इवेट कर दिया या उसको बाईपास कर
दिया या ईडीआर्स को बाईपास कर दिया तो ये
एक बड़ी दिक्कत है फायर वाल्स को बाईपास
कर दिया तो यहां पे ये काम होता है डिफेंस
इवेंशन में तो यहां पे क्या होगा ऑफ
फस्केटिंग पावर शेल स्क्रिप्ट्स अनहोकिंग
इडिया डीएलएस मतलब कि यहां पे अब आपको ऑफ
फस्केटिंग पावर शेल के स्क्रिप्ट्स
मिलेंगे कुछ ऐसे स्क्रिप्ट्स इनकोडेड
स्क्रिप्ट्स कुछ ऐसे स्क्रिप्ट्स जो बनाए
गए हैं इन तरह तरह के इवेशंस के लिए वह
आपको देखने को मिल सकते हैं इन तरह के
अटैक्स को अह लॉन्च करने के लिए जैसे कि
बाईपास करने के लिए इडीएस को एंटीवायरसेस
को वो आपको मिलेंगे। उसके बाद आता है
कमांड एंड कंट्रोल जो अटैकर का मेन
कंट्रोल यूनिट होता है जहां से वो सारा
कुछ कंट्रोल करता है। एस्टैब्लिशिंग एंड
इंक्रिप्टेड बिकॉन होम टू द अटैकर
सर्वर्स। मतलब अब उसने जो एग्जीक्यूट किया
है पेलोड वह पेलोड वापस बैक टू अटैकर्स के
कमांड कंट्रोल सर्वर से कनेक्ट होगा। और
अटैकर के उस सर्वर से कनेक्ट होकर वह
ऑपरेट करना शुरू कर देगा और अटैकर्स को
जानकारियां भेजेगा जो भी कमांड अटैकर इशू
करेगा वो जो पेलोड है उस सिस्टम से वो
चीजें इनेशन निकाल के देगा उस कंपनी के
कंप्यूटर से सर्वर से इनेशन निकाल के देगा
एचटीटीपीएस या डीएनएस टर्नलिंग टू अ
मलेशियस एक्सटर्नल आईपी यानी कि कोई
एचटीटीपीएस टनलिंग हो रही है डीएनएस
टर्नलिंग हो रही है मलेसियस आईपी पे यह
इसमें आता है तो यह पूरी थी आपकी वन टू एट
हमारा फर्स्ट फेज ये सिर्फ फर्स्ट फज़ था।
अभी दो फेज बचे हैं। उस पे आते हैं। टेंशन
मत लीजिए। बहुत इजी है। आपको बहुत ईजीली
मैं समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं ताकि आपको
एक-एक पॉइंट समझ में आ जाए। सेकंड फेज में
है प्रोपगेशन। जैसे मैंने बोला
एक्सपेंडिंग इंटरनल रीच। अब ये अपनी
इंटरनल रीच बढ़ाएगा अटैकर। इसमें प्रोपगेट
करेगा। अब कैसे करेगा प्रोपगेट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वंस इंसाइड
जो पेशेंट ज़ीरो है। वंस इंसाइड पेशेंट
ज़ीरो। बताओ। अच्छा मुझे ये बताओ पेशेंट
जीरो यहां पे का मतलब क्या हुआ? सभी लोग
से मैं पूछ रहा हूं। सभी लोग बताइए।
एवरीवन [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लेट
मी नो व्हाट इज पेशेंट जीरो हियर? व्हाट
डड आई मीन बाय पेशेंट जीरो हियर? आप सभी
लोग बता दीजिए प्लीज। देखूं आप लोगों में
से कितने लोग सही बता रहे हैं। लेट्स सी
बताइए बताइए। फटाफट बताइए। पेशेंस जीरो
क्या है?
किसी का रिप्लाई नहीं आया। मैंने पहले भी
बताया हुआ है पेसेंट ज़ीरो के बारे में।
पेसेंट ज़ीरो के बारे में मैंने पहले भी
बताया हुआ है। PST ज़ीरो किसको बोलेंगे?
मतलब बेसिकली क्या है एग्जैक्टली व्हाट आई
मीन थ्रू अ पेसिंग जीरो
बताइए बताइए बताइए गाइस बताइए इट्स वेरी
ईजी गाइस इट्स नॉट नॉट सो डिफिकल्ट जो
आपको समझ नहीं आ रहा है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
किसी को नहीं पता
नो वन नोस नोबडी नोस भाई
पेशेंट जीरो का मतलब है यार वंस इनसाइड
पेशेंट जीरो द फर्स्ट कंप्यूटर जो
कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया गया है अटैकर के द्वारा
पहला जो कंप्यूटर है मैंने यहां यहां यहां
जो था ना ये फर्स्ट पेज
द गोल इज टू गेट इनसाइड अ सिंगल होस्ट
हां जो पहला कंप्यूटर जो उसने
कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया। यह है पेशेंट ज़ीरो।
वंस इनसाइड द पेशेंट ज़ीरो, द अटैकर नीड्स
टू मूव अराउंड। अब अटैकर को आगे बढ़ना है।
अ सिंगल कॉम्प्रोमाइज़ लैपटॉप यूजुअली डोंट
डज़ नॉट हैव द सेंसिटिव क्राउन ज्वेल डाटा।
क्राउन ज्वेल डाटा मतलब बहुत सेंसिटिव हाई
क्वालिटी डाटा नहीं होती एक सिंगल लैपटॉप
के अंदर। और बहुत सारे कंप्यूटरटर्स होते
हैं। उनके अंदर डाटा मिलेगी सारी। इन दिस
फज़ द अटैकर्स एक्सपेंड देयर रीच इंटरनली।
अब अटैकर अंदर ही अंदर चलना शुरू करेगा।
अंदर ही अंदर फैलना शुरू करेगा। अपने आप
को फैलाएगा। अब उसमें
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वो क्या-क्या
चीजें करता है? तो उसमें वो ये छह चीजें
करता है। ये जो छह स्टेप्स हैं वो करता
है। पहला है पाइवोट। पहले वो पाइवोट
करेगा। यूजिंग द इनिशियल होस्ट एज अ जंप
बॉक्स टू रीच हिडन इंटरनल सबनेट्स।
टर्नलिंग एसेस ट्रैफिक थ्रू अ इंटरनल वेब
सर्वर यह एज एन एसओसी जो है आपको देखने को
मिलेगा कि एक जो यहां पे क्या करेगा?
हमारा जो अटैकर है भैया एडवर्सरी जो है
हमारे वो क्या करेंगे कि जो फर्स्ट होस्ट
है उससे वह जंप करेगा। उससे बाहर निकलेगा
और हिडन इंटरनल सबनेट्स तक इंटरनल जो
मशीनंस जो इंटरनल सबनेट्स हैं जो
नेटवर्क्स हैं वहां तक पहुंचने की कोशिश
करेगा इंटरनल नेटवर्क्स तक कि भैया वहां
तक पहुंचते हैं फिर आगे हम काम करेंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देन आती है
डिस्कवरी। मैपिंग आउट इंटरनल नेटवर्क,
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी एंड एसेट्स। अब ये
इंटरनल नेटवर्क्स को एक्टिव डायरेक्टरीज़
को एसेट्स को मैप करता है। जो भी इंटरनल
नेटवर्क्स हैं, जो भी एक्टिव डायरेक्टरीज़
हैं, जो भी एसेट्स हैं, उनको मैप करेगा।
देखेगा उनका रास्ता सब
मानचित्र बनाएगा या मैप बनाएगा। देखो भाई
कौन कहां पे है देख ले पहले फिर आगे
प्रोसेस करेंगे। रनिंग नेट ग्रुप डोमेन
एडमिनस और ब्लड हाउंड स्कैन्स। अब ब्लड
हाउंड स्कैन्स जो है या नेट ग्रुप डोमेन
एडमिनस इस तरह के कमांड से बेसिकली इंटरनल
नेटवर्क्स की एक डिटेल जो है वो आती है।
एडमिनस डिटेल्स, डोमेन डिटेल्स ये सारी
चीजें आती हैं जो कि एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के
ऊपर में ऑपरेट होती हैं। तो यह काम हमारा
अटैकर करेगा। आप इन टॉपिक्स के बारे में
थोड़ा बहुत देख सकते हैं। Google वैसे कुछ
ज्यादा आपको नीड है नहीं। उसके बाद है
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन। अब गेनिंग हायर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव राइट्स ऑन सिस्टम और
डोमेन। अब वो एक नॉर्मल यूजर की तरह घुसा
था। नॉर्मल यूजर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया था।
बट उससे कुछ हो नहीं रहा है। तो अब वो
अपने प्रिविलेज को एस्केलेट करेगा। और
बोलेगा कि भैया मैं नॉर्मल यूजर नहीं हूं।
मैं रूट या एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर बनूंगा और सब
कुछ तबाह करूंगा। [हंसी] डंपिंग एल्स
मेमोरी फॉर करबेरस एडमिन टिकट्स
मेमिकार्ड्स। तो अब यहां पे यह एलs मेमोरी
को जैसे मैंने बताया था एल्स लॉग इन
Windows लॉग इन के लिए रेस्पोंसिबल होते
हैं। तो यह एलs मेमोरी को डंप करेगा।
मिमिक्स का यूज़ करेगा। ये सब ट्राई करेगा
कि भैया प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन कर पाएं। देन
आती है एग्जीक्यूशन रनिंग मलशियस कोड ऑन
एडिशनल इंटरनल सिस्टम्स। अब ये उन इंटरनल
सिस्टम्स पे मलेशियस कोड को रन करेगा और
अपनी
कोड को रन करके और अपनी इच्छा पूरी करेगा।
ठीक है? ये चीज
उसके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बाद ये
क्या है? रिमोट एग्जीक्यूशन वाया पीएस
एकजेक और डब्ल्यूएमआई कमांड्स।
डब्ल्यूएमआई कमांड्स जो हैं उनके थ्रू या
पीएस एग्जैक्ट कमांड पावर शेल स्क्रिप्ट
कमांड जो पावर शेल के कमांड्स हैं उनके
थ्रू ये क्या करेगा? रिमोट एग्जीक्यूशन
करेगा मलेशियस कोड्स का। मलेशियस कोड्स को
एग्जीक्यूट करने की कोशिश करता है। देन
आती है क्रेडेंशियल एक्से। अब यहां पे ये
क्रेडेंशियल्स चुराएगा, हैशेट चुराएगा,
पासवर्ड्स डंपिंग करेगा। ये सारी चीजें
करेगा कि क्रेडिट चुरा लो भाई ताकि आगे के
काम आसान हो जाए। ठीक है? ये
अब इसमें क्या करेगा? कौन सी फुल कोर्स आप
मांग रहे हैं? बेसिक टू एडवांस जय सरस्वती
जी बताइए कौन सी टॉपिक के डोमेन के मांग
रहे हैं? कीबोर्ड की लॉगिंग करबरोस्टिंग
सर्चिंग प्लेन टेक्स्ट कॉन्फिग फाइल्स ये
सब चीजें जो है इसके अंदर में होती हैं।
मतलब कि बेसिकली की लॉगिंग वगैरह जो होती
है उसके थ्रू ये काम कर सकता है। प्लेन
टेक्स्ट कॉन्फिग फाइल्स सर्च करेगा। ये
सारी चीजें जो है आपको इसके थ्रू मिलने
वाली है। फुल एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स। फुल
एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स हमारी एक हम लेकर आने
वाले हैं। आप सबको चलो इन्होंने पूछा है
तो बता भी देता हूं। हम बहुत जल्द एक दो
दो-तीन दिनों में आपके लिए आप सबों के लिए
एक पार्ट वन फुल एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स लेकर
आएंगे जो कि 5 से छ घंटे की लगभग होने
वाली है और यह पार्ट वन होगा ओनली पार्ट
टू भी आएगा वो पार्ट वन के ऊपर जो
रिस्पांस है उसके ऊपर डिपेंड करता है एंड
उसमें बहुत कुछ रहेगा लिटरली पेड कोर्सेज
में भी आपको उतने नहीं मिलते हैं जितने हम
आपको देंगे उस उन सब चीजों के अंदर में तो
आपको मजा आएगा उन चीजों के अंदर तो जरूर
देखिएगा उसको ठीक है
ओके सोमजीत बिल्कुल बिल्कुल ठीक है लास्ट
में आता है लेटरल मूवमेंट इस फेज के अंदर
में सेकंड फेज के अंदर में लास्ट नहीं है
सेकंड फेज का लास्ट है मूविंग फ्रॉम मशीन
टू मशीन अक्रॉस द इंटरनल नेटवर्क्स अब ये
लास्ट फेज में क्या करते हैं एक मशीन से
दूसरे मशीन दूसरे मशीन से तीसरे मशीन
तीसरे मशीन से चौथे मशीन में ये मशीन में
ये मूव करते हैं हटाकर क्या करता है एक
मशीन से दूसरे मशीन में मूव करता है बस ये
चीज है
ये काम करते हैं लास्ट में यूजिंग स्टोलन
डोमेन एडमिन टोकंस टू आरडीपी इनू सर्व
फम्स मतलब कि डोमेन एडमिन टिकट्स को स्टोर
करना चुराना
जिसके थ्रू वो लॉगिन कर सकते हैं। दूसरे
मशीनंस में घुस सकते हैं। ये काम लेटर
मोमेंट में करते हैं। ये थी सेकंड फेज। तो
फर्स्ट फेज में हमने देखा यहां पे आठ जो
टैक्टिक्स हैं। सेकंड फेज में हमने यहां
पे छह टैक्टिक्स जो हैं वो देखे हैं। ठीक
है? अब यहां पे लास्ट फेज है हमारा एक्शन
फेज। फज़ थ्री। यहां पे अटैकर अपने
एक्चुअली ऑब्जेक्टिव जो है उसका वो किस
काम के लिए अटैक कर रहा है। वो क्या अचीव
करना चाहता था उस अटैक से उसको फुलफिल
करने का काम यहां पे करता है कि अब मैं जो
चीज़ भाई आने करने आया था वो मैं फुलफिल कर
लेता हूं। द अटैकर हैज़ रीच द टारगेट
सर्वर्स। टारगेट सर्व तक पहुंच चुका है।
जैसे कि डेटाबेस, डोमेन कंट्रोलर्स,
क्लाउड स्टोरेज एंड एग्जीक्यूट्स देयर
अल्टीमेट ऑब्जेक्टिव। अब यहां पे अपना
ऑब्जेक्टिव को एग्जीक्यूट करता है। क्या
ऑब्जेक्टिव है? किस तरीके से? क्या करता
है भैया वो? तो वो कलेक्शन करेगा। पहले
इसमें चार [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ही
यहां पे
चार टैक्टिक्स है। कलेक्शन करेगा। क्या
करेगा? गैदरिंग द टारगेटेड फाइल्स एंड
सेंसिटिव डेटा इनू वन स्पॉट। अब वो सारे
सेंसिटिव डेटा, टारगेटेड फाइल्स जो वो
गैदर करना चाहता है, कलेक्ट करना चाहता
है, उसको करना शुरू करेगा। स्टेजिंग डॉट
जिप आर्काइव ऑफ़ कस्टमर डेटाबेस फाइल्स ऑन
डिस्क। एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट आपको क्या
दिखेगा वहां पे? कि आपको जिप फाइल्स
आरकाइव दिख सकती हैं कस्टमर डेटाबेस
फाइल्स के डिस्क के ऊपर। तो आप समझिए कि
कुछ ना कुछ तो गड़बड़ हो रही है। अब जिप
फाइल क्यों है? जब आपने नहीं डाली, किसी
ने नहीं डाला। तो ये जिप फाइल कहां से आ
गई? तो आपको एज अ एसोसियो एनालिस्ट यहां
पे डाउट क्रिएट होगा। आपको ये चीजें देखने
को मिल सकती है जब इस तरह की चीजें होंगी।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उसके बाद आती
है एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन। एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन
स्टेलिंग द कलेक्टेड डेटा आउट ऑफ द
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। इसका मतलब है कि जो डाटा
कलेक्ट किया है उसने अब उसको ऑ्गेनाइजेशन
नेटवर्क से बाहर अपने बॉस को भेजना है।
कमांड कंट्रोल जो चला रहा है जो अटैकर है
उसके पास जाएगा यह डाटा तो यह डाटा चुराने
वाली काम होगी फिर तो अब एसओसी को क्या
दिखेगा अपलोडिंग इंक्रिप्टेड जिप फाइल्स
टू मेगा और वाया एसटीडीp पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट
मतलब जो भी मेगा ये मेगा बहुत पॉपुलर
वेबसाइट है जहां पे लार्ज फाइल सेट्स जो
है हटाकर जो है अपलोड करते हैं डाउनलोड
करते हैं इसको यूज़ किया जाता है जनरली तो
यहां पे अपलोड हो रही है या कोई और
वेबसाइट पे अपलोड हो रही है तो यहां पे
कुछ प्रॉब्लमेटिक ये स्टेप यह थोड़ा सा अह
अह कान खड़े करने वाले स्टेप है कि एज एन
एसोसिएलिस्ट वहां दिक्कत आएगी। वहां पे
ऐसा लगेगा अरे भाई यह क्या हो रहा है?
अपलोड हो रही है फाइल्स तो गड़बड़ है ये
तो ठीक है।
ओके आई विल कम टू योर क्वेश्चन।
गन ड्रिफ्ट यूजर हैंडल जो भी है विल आई
विल कम टू योर क्वेश्चन प्लीज वेट अ बिट
पहले ये हम टॉपिक वाली चीजें कर लेते हैं
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] देन
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन के बाद आता है इंपैक्ट
इंपैक्ट का मतलब डिसररप्टिंग करप्टिंग
डिस्ट्रइंग बिज़नेस ऑपरेशन अब ये डिसरप्ट
करेंगे करप्ट करेंगे रैंसम वेयर वगैरह का
केस ऐसे ही तो होता है अटैक जब होती है
लॉक्स फाइल के एक्सटेंशन चेंज हो जाते हैं
फाइल्स को लॉक कर दिए जाते हैं रैंसम
डिमांड किया जाता है फाइल्स को डिलीट भी
कर दिए जाते हैं कई केसेस में। तो, यह
चीजें होती हैं। डिप्लइंग रसमवेयर,
इंक्रिप्टिंग डिस्कस और वाइपिंग बैकअप्स।
बैकअप्स को हटा दिया, लॉग्स को पूरे मतलब
सब चीजें हटा दी। इंक्रिप्ट कर दिया
डिस्कस को। ये सारी काम होते हैं इंपैक्ट
में। और लास्ट होता है ऑब्जेक्टिव
फुलफिलिंग द मास्टर इंटेंट ऑफ़ द अटैक।
फाइनेंसियल एक्सटॉर्शन, स्टेट स्पैनिज,
रेपुटेशन डिस्ट्रक्शंस ये सारी चीज़ होती
है। जब अब ये अटैकर इसने इतना बड़ा अटैक
क्यों किया है? इतना बड़ा अटैक क्यों किया
है? अपने किसी ऑब्जेक्टिव को फुलफिल करने
के लिए। सो अब वो ऑब्जेक्टिव फुलफिल करना
शुरू करेगा। अगर कोई फाइनेंसियल एक्सटॉशन
करना चाहते हैं लाइक काइंड ऑफ एक्सट
एक्सटॉर्शन अगर कोई करना चाहता है तो दे
विल डू दोज़ हैकर्स विल डू फाइनेंसियल
एक्सटॉर्शन रसवेयर टाइप से डिमांड वो
करेगा वो अपना स्टेट स्पनिज़ है वो अह किसी
लाइक स्टेट स्पों्सर्ड हैकर्स होते हैं जो
स्टेट के द्वारा स्पॉन्सर्ड किए जाते हैं
स्टेट मतलब गवर्नमेंट के द्वारा उस तरह के
भी अटैक्स होते हैं और रेपुटेशन बहुत सारे
कंपनीज़ के रेपुटेशन के या इंडिविजुअल के
रेपुटेशन को डिस्ट्रॉय करने के लिए अटैक्स
किए जाते हैं। तो वो भी इस तरह की चीजें
अपना ऑब्जेक्टिव फुलफिल करते हैं। तो ये
पूरा का पूरा जो है आपका फज़ था। यहां पे
बेसिकली यहां पे तीन फेजेस हमने डील किए
और उसके अंदर 18 टैक्टिक्स को डील किया।
पहले फेज में यहां पे आठ टैक्टिक्स थे।
दूसरे फेज में यहां पे छह टैक्टिक्स थे।
ठीक है? और तीसरे फेज में यहां पे आपके
चार रिमेनिंग टैक्टिक्स थे। तो यह हमने
इसको कवर किया है। यह था पूरा का पूरा
यूनिफाइड किल चेन के अंदर के टैक्टिक्स।
यह सारी चीजें। अब
यहां पे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अ सीनियर एसोसिए एनालिस्ट जो होता है वो
यूकेसी को यूनिफाइड किल चेन को कैसे यूज़
करता है? मतलब कैसे इसको यूज़ करेगा? एक
सीनियर एनालिस्ट इन डे टू डे ऑपरेशंस द
यूनिफाइड किल चेन प्रोवाइड्स द नैरेटिव
फ्रेम फॉर इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस। बेसिकली ये
जो यूकेसी है इसको सीनियर एनालिस्ट ही कवर
करते हैं। बट यहां पे मैंने पहले ही बोला
था कि ये एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट का एक है तो
जॉब रेडी फ्री ट्रेनिंग। बिल्कुल जॉब रेडी
फ्री ट्रेनिंग है। बिल्कुल एंड L1 का है
ये। इट्स नॉट फॉर L2 L3 बट स्टिल आई वुड
लव टू टीच यू अबाउट सम टॉपिक्स जो L2 L3
से भी रिलेट करते हैं। कहीं ना कहीं अगर
आपको पता होंगे तो इंटरव्यू में आपका एक
अपर हैंड होगा। एंड बाकी कैंडिडेट से शायद
आप थोड़ा अच्छा परफॉर्म कर पाएंगे। आपको
चीजें पता होंगी, टॉपिक्स पता होंगी। कहीं
आपसे कोई क्वेश्चन अपर लेवल का कुछ पूछ दे
कुछ भी L2 L3 लेवल का तो आपको पता होना
चाहिए चीजें। दैट्स व्हाई इट्सेंट। राइट?
यस प्लीज आस्क क्वेश्चन। अब यहां पे एसओसी
क्या करता है? अलर्ट मैपिंग डिटरमाइनिंग
डल टाइम एंड स्कोप ब्रेकिंग द चेन। व्हेन
मल्टीपल अलर्ट्स फाइल फायर इन योर एसआईएम
यू मैप देम टू यूकेसी। मल्टीपल जब अलर्ट्स
फायर होंगे तो उनको आप यूकेसी यूनिफाइड
किल चेन में मैप करेंगे उनके फेजेस के
अकॉर्डिंग एन अलर्ट ऑफ़ फिशिंग लिंक क्लिक
इज़ फज़ वन इनफिल्ट्रेशन इनफिल्ट्रेशन है।
एन अलर्ट फॉर एल्स मेमोरी रीड इज़ फज़ टू
प्रोपगेशन। तो अगर आपको अलॉट फिशिंग लिंक
क्लिक का आ रहा है तो यह एक फज़ वन का मैप
होगा कि अरे यह तो फज़ वन का अटैक है।
इनफिल्ट्रेशन हुआ है। अभी अभी तो बहुत अपर
ले बहुत ही लोअर लेवल पे यह अटैक चल रहा
है। आसानी से ब्लॉक कर दो। और अगर एल्स एस
मेमोरी लीड का हो रहा है तो ये फज़ टू का
है। प्रोपगेशन वाला है। थोड़ा सा
प्रॉब्लमेटिक है। तो ये पता चल जाता है।
उसके बाद डिटरमाइनिंग ड्यूल टाइम एंड
स्कोप। ड्यूल टाइम का मतलब मैंने बताया
हुआ था पहले कि एक अटैकर एक जब कोई
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर रहा है वो कितने देर तक
उस पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क के अंदर में बैठा
हुआ है। कितने देर से वो उस नेटवर्क को
नेटवर्क के अंदर में सेट किया हुआ है।
बैठा हुआ है। इफ एन इंसिडेंट इज़ कॉट इन
फेज वन इट इज़ अ कंटेंड इवेंट। यह कंटेन
इवेंट होता है। बट इफ एन इंसिडेंट रीचेस
फज़ टू और फज़ थ्री इट इज़ एन एक्टिव
एंटरप्राइज ब्रच ट्रिगरिंग होस्ट आइसोलेशन
पासवर्ड रिसेट अक्रॉस एक्टिव डायरेक्टरीज़
एंड एग्जीक्यूटिव एक्सलेशन। और अगर फज़ वन
में कोई अगर पर्टिकुलर इंसिडेंट है तब तो
उसको माना जाता है कि चलो फज़ वन में इसको
रोका जा सकता है आराम से। कोई बड़ी बात
नहीं। बट फज़ टू और फज़ थ्री में चला जाए तो
उसको हम एक्टिव इंटरप्राइज ब्रीच बोलेंगे।
और यहां पे होस्ट को आइसोलेट करना, हटा
देना, बाकी होस्ट से पासवर्ड को रिसेट कर
देना। सारे नेटवर्क की ये सारी चीजें करनी
पड़ जाती है। तीसरा है ब्रेकिंग द चेन। टू
स्टॉप एन अटैक एसोसिएट डज़ नॉट नीड टू
ब्लॉक एव्री टैक्टिक। दे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ओनली नीड टू
ब्रेक वन लिंक इन द चेन बिफोर द अटैकर
रीचेस फज़ थ्री। तो अगर आपको इस तरह के
बड़े अटैक को एज एन एसोसिए एनालिस्ट रोकना
है तो आपको जरूरी नहीं है कि हर टैक्टिक्स
हर फेज के हर टैक्टिक्स को रोका जाए। आप
फेज थ्री में उनके पहुंचने से पहले ही
किसी एक चेन को ब्रेक कर देते हैं तो वहां
पे वो अटैक मोस्ट प्रोबेबबली रोक दी जाती
है। रुक जाती है। ब्लॉक द लैटरल मूवमेंट
इन फ टू एंड अटैकर नेवर गेट्स टू
एक्सफिल्ट्रेट इन फ थ्री। सिंपल सा फंडा
है। सिंपल कि आप फज़ टू के लैटरल मूवमेंट
को ब्लॉक कर दीजिए। मतलब एक मशीन से दूसरे
मशीन में जो ट्रैवल कर रहा है एक नेटवर्क
से दूसरे नेटवर्क में। वहीं पे वो आगे का
काम ही नहीं कर पाएगा। फज़ थ्री का एक्स
फिल्ट्रेट करके डेटा को भेजना उसने का काम
ही नहीं कर पाए। उसका लिंक ही टूट गया
यार। अब वो तो खत्म वो नहीं कर पाएगा। दिस
इज़ हाउ एज़ एन एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट
यूकेसी यूनिफाइड किल चेन इज़ बीन यूज़्ड। आई
होप आपको यह क्लियर हो गई होगी। अब एक
लास्ट चीज है वो है कंपैरिजन का जो मैंने
डाला हुआ है यहां पे साइबर केचन में मथ्रे
में और यूकेसी में इन तीनों में मैंने
कंपैरिजन किया है ताकि आपको और ज्यादा
थोड़ी क्लेरिटी मिल जाए। सो व्हाट इज़ द
कंपैरिजन इज़ अबाउट? फर्स्ट वी हैव नोटेड द
फ्रेमवर्क्स, देन स्कोप देन फोकस देन
ऑपरेशनल एडवांटेज। तो पहले हम लॉकिड
मार्टिन का जो पुराना साइबर किल्लचन है
उसके बारे में बात करते हैं। इसमें
फिर मतरे में एंड फिर यूनिफाइड केशिया
में। ठीक है? अलग-अलग यहां पे बातें करते
हैं। देखो तो लॉकिड मार्टिन में स्कोप की
बात करें तो सेवन स्टेप्स के होते हैं।
मथ्रे में ग्रैनुअल 100्स ऑफ टेक्निक्स
होते हैं। हालांकि इसमें भी वो होते हैं
लेकिन 100्स ऑफ टेक्निक्स बहुत सारे होते
हैं इसके अंदर में।
एंड यूनिफाइड किल चेन में 18 टैक्टिक्स
होते हैं। तीन फेस में डिवाइड होते हैं।
सिंपल फोकस की बात करें तो यह पेरीमीटर
डिफेंस एंड प्रिवेंशन करता है। मतलब बाहर
बाहर से सुरक्षा
मैथ्रे स्पेसिफिक अटैकर बिहेवियर को
टारगेट करता है। अटैकर का बिहेवियर
स्पेसिफिक क्या है उसको भी टारगेट करता
है। और यूनिफाइड किल चेन फुल अटैक साइकिल
बाहर से लेके अंदर घुसने तक की जितनी पूरी
अटैक साइकिल है सबको कवर करता है।
यूनिफाइड इज़ गुड। मस्त है यह। ऑपरेशनल
एडवांटेज देखते हैं। सिंपल टू अंडरस्टैंड
फॉर मैनेजमेंट बट आउटडेटेड फॉर इंटरनल
ब्रचेज। मैं ये बहुत आसान है समझना। साइबर
किल चेंज जो पुराना वाला है इसको बहुत
इज़ली समझा जा सकता है। मैनेजमेंट के लिए
आसान है। बट ये इंटरनल ब्रीच पे एप्लीकेबल
नहीं है। इंटरनल ब्रीच हो रहा है। इंटरनली
अगर घुस चुका है अटैकर तो मुश्किल खड़ी कर
सकता है। मत क्या है भैया? मथ्रे क्या है?
एस एक्सीलेंट टैक्टिकल डिक्शनरी फॉर ईडीआर
एसआईएम रूल्स बट लैक्स अ क्रोनोलॉजिकल
नैरेटिव। यह बहुत अच्छा है। एडीआर एसआईएम
रूल्स के लिए बहुत अच्छा है। बट स्टिल कुछ
चीजों में यह लैग करता है। कुछ चीजों में
इसके कुछ अ
ड्रॉबैक्स यू कैन से कुछ या कुछ चीजें कमी
है इसके अंदर में जो यहां पे यूनिफाइड किल
चेन फुलफिल करेगा। जो कि क्या करता है?
कंबाइन माइथिस डेप्थ विद द किल चेस
स्ट्रेटेजिक टाइम लाइन। अब यह यूनिफाइड
क्या करता है? इन दोनों को मिला देता है।
दे कंबाइन बोथ इन दोनों को मिला देता है।
किसको? साइबर किल चेन को भी और मथ्रे वाली
जो प्रोसेस है मिला के और एक मस्त एक
यूनिफाइड एक किल चेन बनाता है। एंड एक
पूरी डिटेल्ड अंदर बाहर पूरा मॉनिटर करता
है। मैपिंग करता है अटैकर के लाइफ साइकिल
को। कंप्लीट साइकिल 10 द डिफरेंस बिटवीन द
साइबर किल चेन मथ्रे एंड यूकेसी दैट्स इट
तो यह थी पूरी आपकी आज की कहानी फुल कहानी
दिस दिस वाज़
दैट्स इट। ये पूरी कहानी थी। अब यहां पे
इसको तो हम हटा देते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब यहां पे
मैं आपको कुछ चीजें बताना चाहूंगा। अभी भी
अभी यह कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ। मैं आपको बताता
हूं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
ट्राई हैक मी के ऊपर। यहां पर आप देख सकते
हैं। यह रूम इनफो यह फ्री रूम है।
यूनिफाइड किलचे रूम इनफो दिस इज आल्सो
फ्री रूम ट्राईक के ऊपर में पिरामिड ऑफ
पेन और यूनिफाइड किलचे के रूम्स हैं। आपका
एज अ टास्क है कि आप इन रूम्स को कंप्लीट
कीजिएगा। यह रूम्स बहुत आसान है। बहुत इजी
है इनको कंप्लीट करना। बिकॉज़ यह तो फ्री
है। तो, आप इनको पैसा आपको देना नहीं है।
फ्री अकाउंट लॉगिन कीजिए और यह रूम्स
सॉल्व करना शुरू कर दीजिए। इससे आपको एक
अच्छी प्रैक्टिस हो जाएगी। दैट्स इट। तो
यह पेन पिरामिड ऑफ पेन को 100% 200% तरीके
से इसको सॉल्व कीजिएगा। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट
इट्स वेरीेंट एज अ टास्क कर लीजिएगा और
Lindin पेेंट पॉइंट्स को नोट करके और हमें
टैग कीजिएगा डेफोनिक्स को याद कीजिएगा। ये
एज अ टास्क इनर है। उसी तरीके से यूनिफाइड
किलचेन का भी है। ये भी बहुत इजी टू
गो थ्रू है। काफी इजी है इसको सॉल्व करना।
काफी ईजी है। आप इसको भी गो थ्रू करके इन
रूम को भी सॉल्व कर लीजिएगा। मजा आ जाएगा
आपको। को और भी क्लेरिटी के साथ जो है आप
थोड़ा सा हैंड्स ऑन प्रैक्टिस करेंगे आपको
मजा आएगा। ठीक है? ये फ्री रूम्स थे इसलिए
मैंने कवर नहीं किया है। अगर पेड होते तो
मैं कवर करता जरूर क्योंकि जितने भी पेड
रूम्स हैं आई हैव कवर्ड। ओके? फ्री रूम्स
मैं आपको टास्क देता हूं ताकि आप क्योंकि
आप खुद भी कर सकते हैं। तो ऑब्वियस सी बात
है मैं अगर करूंगा तो वो टाइम वेस्ट है एक
तरह का। आप खुद का एफर्ट डालिए। खुद अपना
एफर्ट वहां पे लगाइए। दूसरी चीज और मैंने
फिर से मैं फिर से एक बार जाते जाने से
पहले एक बार बता देता हूं। कि हां इनफ है।
ट्राईकमी के रूम्स इनफ है आपके लिए। गौरव
इट्स मोर देन इनफ फिलहाल के लिए एसओसी एल1
के लिए इनफ है। एट द एंड अगेन मैं बोलूंगा
कि यह भी टास्क है आपको कि मत वाली ये जो
वीडियो है मथ्रे अटैक फॉर एसओसी ये वीडियो
सेक्शन में मिलेगी। लाइव में नहीं मिलेगी।
इसको जरूर देखिएगा। दिस इज़ वेरीेंट। इसलिए
मैंने इसको कवर नहीं किया है। और साइबर
किलचे की भी वीडियो है। इसको भी जरूर
देखिएगा। और साइबर किलचे मैंने भी बताया
है एसओसी के। आप लाइव में जाइएगा एसओसी की
क्लास नंबर फाइव में तो आपको फाइव में
पूरी साइबर के चेन जो है वो आपको मिल
जाएगी। तो प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट कि आप
इन वीडियोस को भी जरूर देखिएगा। इट्स वेरी
वेरीेंट फॉर योर इंटरव्यूज। अगर आप
इंटरव्यूज में इन वीडियोस को देख के नहीं
जाएंगे तो आपका इंटरव्यू शायद क्लियर नहीं
हो पाएगा क्योंकि ये उस लेवल केेंस होल्ड
करते हैं आपके एसओसी एल वन जर्नी के अंदर
में। दैट्स इट। तो आई थिंक आई एम क्लियर
एवरीवन। मुझे बताइए सब क्लियर है जो मैंने
अभी बताया क्लियर है एवरीबडी क्लियर
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस क्लियर
ठीक है क्लियर है चलिए अच्छी बात है नाउ
नाउ चलिए लेट्स ओके लेट्स लेट्स स्टार्ट।
चलिए अब हम क्वेश्चंस में जो कुछेंट
क्वेश्चंस थे वो ले लेता हूं। जो भी
क्वेश्चंस पूछ रहे थे आई रिक्वेस्ट
एवरीबॉडी टू प्लीज पुट योर क्वेश्चंस वंस
अगेन एक बार चैट में क्योंकि ऊपर चले जाते
हैं तो एग्जैक्टली मिल नहीं पाता है सही
से। तो आप एक बार प्लीज क्वेश्चन पुट कर
दीजिए एंड आई विल पिक दैट क्वेश्चन। ठीक
है? यहां पे पहले क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं।
सर प्लीज रिप्लाई आई ट्राई टू कांटेक्ट
फॉर डीसीएसपी कोर्स बिकॉज़ आई एम कंप्लीट
योर बेस्ट डीएचई कोर्स। डीसीएसपी का आपको
टेंशन नहीं लेना है। डीसीएसपी की ट्रेनिंग
जैसे ही आएगी आने वाली है बहुत जल्द आने
वाली है। उसकी अनाउंसमेंट हो जाएगी
WhatsApp ग्रुप्स के अंदर में चैनल के ऊपर
में YouTube के ऊपर में आपको पता चल
जाएगा। एक विद इन अ मंथ अनाउंसमेंट होने
के चांसेस हैं उसके। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके।
ठीक है।
ओके। गन ड्रिफ्ट अमन श्रीवास्तव हां जी
अमन श्रीवास्तव जी आपका क्वेश्चन क्या था
जस्ट लेट मी स्क्रॉल थ्रू
अ या
हे आई एम वेरी न्यू टू हियर आई गॉट
रिकमेंडेशन ऑफ योर चैनल बाय वन ऑफ़ माय
फ्रेंड वर्किंग इन फाई इन द साइबर
सिक्योरिटी टीम ओके हिज़ वर्क मोस्टली
इनवॉल्व्स अराउंड वेब पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
ठीक है हाउएवर अबाउट मी आई हैव कंप्लीटेड
एमबीए इन मार्केट मार्केटिंग एंड बिज़नेस
एनालिटिक एनालिसिस बट आई गॉट अ जॉब इन
सेल्स दैट आई वांट टू चेंज। आई एम मोर
इंटरेस्टेड इन साइबर सिक्योरिटी। प्लीज
गाइड मी इफ आई कैन क्रैक। ठीक है?
आपने ग्रेजुएशन
कहां पे किया अमन? आपने ग्रेजुएशन किस चीज
से करी है? वो एक बार बता दीजिए। टेक
नॉनटेक है या टेक है? अमन एज एन एमबीए आई
कैन आई क्रैक द जॉब इन दिस फील्ड? और
उन्होंने प्रॉब्लम? प्लीज यस लेट मी नो द
पाथ। पहले आप बता दीजिए कि आपने ग्रेजुएशन
कहां से? एमटेक बीटेक एंड या कोई नॉन टेक
आपका बैकग्राउंड रहा है। सो लेट मी नो।
ओके योगी योगी योग योगी सो प्लीज एक्सेप्ट
ओके जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
ओके
चलिए। सो
हम तो
बीएससी मैथमेटिक्स। सो आई थिंक चलिए साइंस
है, बीएससी है। अह सो मे बी इट माइट बी
कंसीडरेबल। आई डोंट नो एग्ज़ैक्टली कि कई
सारे जो कंपनीज़ हैं वह रिजेक्ट कर देते
हैं वैसे तो। बट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] या यू कैन
गिव इट ट्राई। अगर आपके अंदर स्किल होगी
तो डेफिनेटली यू वुड गेट द पॉजिटिव आउटपुट
पॉजिटिव रिस्पांससेस फ्रॉम कंपनीज़। तो
आपको स्किल पे पहले काम करना है। पहले ये
नहीं सोचना है कि इफ आई एम एमबीए और
समथिंग लाइक दैट। अगर आपको स्विच करना है
और स्किल पे आप काम करते हैं। यू हैव टू
गिव एटलीस्ट सिक्स टू सेवन मंथ्स एट लीस्ट
टू शार्पेन योर स्किल्स टू गेन द डे
पर्टिकुलर स्किल्स। देन आप अप्लाई कर सकते
हैं। एमबीए के बेसिस पे नहीं बीएससी के
बेसिस पे कर सकते हैं।
सर आई एम इन थर्ड ईयर ऑफ़ कंप्यूटर
इंजीनियरिंग। आई वांट बी अ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। साइबर सिक्योरिटी होना चाहते
हो या साइबर सिक्योरिटी स्पेशलिस्ट।
हाउएवर देयर इज़ नो साइबर सिक्योरिटी
कंपनीज़ कमिंग इन आवर कॉलेज रिलेटेड टू इट।
अभी तो थर्ड ईयर में हो यार। तो अभी तो
आराम करो। थर्ड ईयर में क्या ही कॉलेज में
आएंगे कंपनीज़? अगर नहीं भी आते हैं आपके
कॉलेज में। फोर्थ ईयर में भी नहीं आते
हैं। टेंशन नहीं लेनी है। ठीक है? मेरे भी
कंपनी कॉलेज में नहीं आते थे
साइबर सिक्योरिटी के लिए या किसी भी डोमेन
के लिए। आज मैं भी कुछ ना कुछ कर ही रहा
हूं। राइट? तो आप भी करेंगे। आप अपने
स्किल्स पे फोकस कीजिए। आप अपनी टैलेंट को
समझिए। आप समझिए कि आपके अंदर क्या टैलेंट
है। आपके अंदर कितनी डेप्थ है टैलेंट की।
उस स्किल को ऑक्यूुपाई कीजिए और उस स्किल
पे काम कीजिए। स्किल ही आपको जॉब दिलाएगी।
मेरे कांटेक्ट में बहुत ऐसे लोग हैं जिनके
पास कोई डिग्री कोई सर्टिफिकेशन नहीं है।
कुछ भी नहीं है और स्किल के बेसिस पे वो
बहुत अच्छे लेवल पे लाखों रुपए की मंथली
इनकम कमा रहे हैं। तो आपकी स्किल मैटर
करते हैं। नथिंग एल्स।
ठीक है?
इग्नोर नहीं करते भाई हम किसी को भी। आपके
मैसेज छूट जाते होंगे। चलो इग्नोर नहीं
किया है। सर आई एम डूइंग योर बग बंटी
कोर्स। इज दैट यू हैव यूज्ड द ओशियन। ऑल
दैट कैन हैपन ऑल काली। यूज़ द ओशियन है।
डिस्ट्रिक्ट ओसियन बोल रहे हो? हां हां
काली पे हो सकता है आपका। बिल्कुल काली पे
हो सकता है सब कुछ। काली पे हो सकता है।
नो इशज़
हो सकता है। कोई इशू नहीं है।
सर सर व्हाई डू यू टेक अननेसेसरी फूड? कौन
सा अननेसेसरी फूड? भाई तुम्हें क्या पता
मैं क्या खाता हूं। कुछ भी
व्हेन यू व्हेन यू टेकिंग वीएपीटी क्लास
वीएपीटी क्लास आएगा बहुत जल्दी आएगा टेंशन
मत लो बहुत जल्दी आएगा
बहुत अच्छी बात है आपने 10 वीडियोस
कंप्लीट कर लिए दैट्स गुड
अ गन ड्रिफ्ट अमन हाउ आई शुड प्रिपेयर अभी
तो आपको मैं रोड मैप नहीं दे सकता
ऑब्वियसली आपके लिए मैं आपको बता देता हूं
सभी को बता देता हूं जनरली जिनको भी नहीं
पता सो लेट मी क्लियर इट बहुत लोगों को
रोड मैप चाहिए होता है। जिनको कुछ नहीं
पता साइबर सिक्योरिटी में क्या करना है,
कैसे करना है, कैसे आगे बढ़ना है। दे वांट
अ रोड मैप। ऑलरेडी मैंने रोड मैप लिया हुआ
है। बट कई लोगों को पता ही नहीं होता या
वीडियोस ही नहीं एक्सप्लोर करते चैनल के
ऊपर में। अब एक चैनल के ऊपर अगर आप आए हो
तो उसको पूरा एक्सप्लोर तो करो एटलीस्ट कि
चैनल पे क्या-क्या वीडियोस हैं? किस-किस
टॉपिक पे हैं। तो आपको मिल जाएगी। अगर
एक्सप्लोर आपने करा होता तो आप देखो अभी
स्क्रॉल करके सबसे नीचे चले जाना चैनल पे।
ठीक है? यहां आके एक वीडियो आपको मिलेगी
साइबर सिक्योरिटी करियर रोड मैप फ्रॉम
ज़ीरो टू प्रो। इस रोड मैप को अमन आई एम
टेलिंग टू यू आल्सो एंड अदर्स जो रोड मैप
चाहते हैं ना एक प्रॉपर जैसे आपने पूछा तो
आपको एक ऐसा परफेक्ट प्रॉपर ना चीजें आपको
पता चलंगी रोड मैप पता चल जाएगा क्या करना
है कैसे करना है सारी चीजें इसमें इसमें
हर चीज भरी पड़ी है ठीक है तो प्लीज गो
एंड वॉच दिस वीडियो डेफिनेटली मस्ट
ओके
थैंक यू सर फॉर गिविंग फ्री सीरीज वेरी
हेल्पफुल यू आर वेल वेलकम
या वेलकम वेलकम एसओसी जॉब रिक्वायरमेंट्स
कोई बात नहीं एसओसी के वीडियोस देखो सब
पता चल जाएगा क्या जॉब रिक्वायरमेंट है
क्या है सब
ओके
आई होप कि अमन यू वुड फॉलो द रोड मैप आपको
रोड मैप समझ में आ जाएगा एक्सक्टली क्या
है
सर, आई एम विदाउट अ डिग्री। जस्ट फोकसिंग
ऑन हैंड्स ऑन स्किल्स एंड हैव पास 12th।
आई कैन गेट अ जॉब बिकॉज़ आई कैन गेट अ जॉब
बिकॉज़
अ आई बिलोंग टू अ पुअर फैमिली। हेंस आई
कैन नॉट अफोर्ड एन एक्सपेंसिव सर्टिफिकेशन
और डिग्री। देखो, डिग्री छोड़ना अच्छी बात
नहीं है। पहले ही मैं बता रहा हूं आपको।
आई एम क्लियरली सेइंग यू। डिग्री को
छोड़ना अच्छी बात नहीं है। और डिग्री पे
ही डिपेंड होना अच्छी बात नहीं है।
स्किल्स तो लेना ही लेना है। मैं सभी न्यू
कमर्स और जो भी मेरे यंग भाई बहन लोग हैं
जो साइबर सिक्योरिटी में करियर बनाना
चाहते हैं, करियर एक देख रहे हैं जिनको
कुछ नहीं पता अभी और अभी 12th पास आउट किए
हैं या पास करने वाले हैं उनसे मेरी एक
रिक्वेस्ट है कि आपको डिग्री कंप्लीट करनी
ही करनी है। सर्टिफिकेशन मत करो। कोई और
साइबर सिक्योरिटी के सर्टिफिकेशन जो
महंगे-महंगे आते हैं उसको मत करो। डिग्री
करनी है आपको और कोशिश करनी है कि शुरू से
ही आप एक टेक डिग्री को कंप्लीट करें। नॉन
टेक नहीं टेक डिग्री को आप कंप्लीट करें।
एक टेक डिग्री को पे फोकस करें आप। चाहे
वो बीएससीआईटी है, चाहे वो बीसीए है, चाहे
वो आपका बीटेक हो गया कि कोई भी एक टेक
डिग्री वो आपके लिए यूज़फुल होगी। कई
कंपनीज़ क्या करती हैं कि अगर आपके पास
डिग्री ही नहीं है ना कोई बैचलर डिग्री तो
आपको वहीं पर रिजेक्ट कर देंगे। आप अपनी
स्किल्स को कहां शोकेस कर पाएंगे? तो वो
तो चाहिए ना यार। वो करना है आपको। ठीक
है? इट्स इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। वो कीजिए। अगर
आप रेगुलर क्लासेस करने वाले नहीं है,
नहीं कर सकते हैं तो आप इग्नू का इग्नू के
जो डिग्रीज होते हैं इग्नू से कीजिए। आईजी
एनओयू इग्नू जो ओपन डिस्टेंस लर्निंग का
प्लेटफार्म प्रोवाइड करती है और इसकी
डिग्रीज ऑल ओवर इंडिया में वैलिड है। बाहर
वैलिड है। यूपीएससी जैसे गवर्नमेंट
एग्जाम्स में वैलिड होते हैं। तो ये
डिस्टेंस ओपन डिस्टेंस लर्निंग है। आप
बीसीए इसकी एक ऑनलाइन बीसीए ट्रेनिंग आती
है। कोर्स आती है। घर बैठे-बैठे पूरा
बीसीए घर से एग्जाम सब कुछ घर से होता है।
आप उसको
चूज़ कर सकते हैं। फी भी कम होती है।
प्राइवेट जो होते हैं इंस्टीट्यूशन उससे
काफी कम होती है प्राइवेट कॉलेज
यूनिवर्सिटी तो आप अगर वैसा ऑप्शन चाहते
हैं तो आप कीजिए बट डिग्री जरूर कीजिए
इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू एवरीबॉडी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक है
अ थैंक यू करेंटली वेयर आई एम वर्किंग दे
आर ऑफरिंग 7.2 लाख पर एनम सो इन कंपैरिजन
टू दैट व्हाट शुड आई एक्सपेक्ट जस्ट लेट
मी नो द बेयर मिनिमम आपका वो तो
एक्सपीरियंस मैटर ही नहीं करेगा अमन आप एक
फ्रेशर की तरह ट्रीट किए जाएंगे। बिकॉज़
करेंटली यू आर इन मार्केटिंग फील्ड एंड यू
आर इन देयर विद द योर एमबीए डिग्री। जब आप
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में आएंगे यू विल बी
कंसीडर्ड फ्रेशर। आप स्टार्टिंग 20,25,000
300 से ज्यादा नहीं होगी। लगभग इसी के
अराउंड आपकी रहेगी। बट एक साल तक अगर आपने
उसको झेल लिया, उस उस टाइमलाइन को झेल
लिया, तो आपको एक अच्छी हक मिल सकती है।
एंड यू विल गेट गुड मनी। यू कैन गेट गुड
मनी। यह मैं आपको बोल सकता हूं। स्किल
होनी चाहिए। फिर आपको अच्छी हाइट मिलेगी।
सर आई एम न्यू लर्नर। वेलकम न्यू लर्नर।
आपका बहुत-बहुत स्वागत है न्यू लर्नर्स
का।
हाउ टू बिकम अ ब्लैकहेट हैकर? नहीं पता
भाई मुझे।
ट्रेनिंग ट्रेनिंग लिख सकते हैं इन Lindin
लाइक ऐड इन अ एक्सपीरियंस ऑफ़ ट्रेनिंग
फ्रॉम डेफ़ोनिक्स। हां लिख दो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। ऐसे लिख दो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है।
सर एसओसी एल1 में वर्क फ्रॉम होम होती है।
नहीं भाई वर्क फ्रॉम होम में जब तक आप अह
एज अ सर्विस एसओसी एज अ सर्विस प्लेटफार्म
यूज़ नहीं कर रहे हैं जो क्लाउड वाली होती
है तब तक वो वर्क फ्रॉम होम कहां से होगा?
ऑफिस से ही करना होगा मोस्टली।
सर, आई हैव डन बी वॉक इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। बट आई डिड नॉट गेट अ जॉब।
व्हाट शुड आई डू? आई एम टायर्ड ऑफ़ फ्लाइंग
एवरीव्हेयर। व्हाट शुड आई डू? वी वॉक क्या
होती है भाई? ये तो पहली डिग्री सुनी है
मैंने। मुझे नहीं पता इसके बारे में। अब
कंपनीज़ उसको अगर एक्सेप्ट करती है तो यू
कैन तभी कुछ होगा ना।
सर इज़ एसएल वन सर्टिफिकेशन ऑन ट्राई हैक
मी यूज़फुल फॉर अ जॉब। इसका मैं कोई गारंटी
आपको नहीं दे सकता क्योंकि बहुत सारी अभी
कंपनीज़ इसको कंसीडर नहीं करते हैं। अब
उनका अच्छा सर्टिफिकेशन है। मैंने सुना
है। बट जॉब के लिए कितनी वह है? इंडिया
में तो खैर उसकी कोई अभी कुछ खास है नहीं।
इंडिया में आज भी वही सब चलता है जो अ
हमेशा से चलता आ रहा है। बाकी
फॉरेन में इसके हैं थोड़े बहुत बट इंडिया
में अभी कुछ खास उनका इंपैक्ट नहीं है।
ठीक है? चलिए आई हैव टूक द क्वेश्चंस
फ्रॉम मेनी ऑफ यू राइट?
ओके। सो आई हैव टू द क्वेश्चंस गाइस। एंड
थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन।
जाते-जाते लाइक जरूर ठोक के जाना। याद
रखना लाइक ठोक के जाना है। टॉप फैंस की
लिस्ट देख लेते हैं। सो दिस इज द टॉप फैंस
लिस्ट। अगेन
सभी लोग हैं जो यूजुअली रहते हैं यहां पे।
या ऑलमोस्ट पीपल आर प्रेजेंट हियर। आई
थिंक
या ऑलमोस्ट पीपल आर प्रेजेंट। कुछ लोग
नहीं है। ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं है। चलेगा।
एंड
हाउ मेनी मोर टॉपिक्स आर लेट? कुछ टॉपिक्स
बचे हैं ज्यादा नहीं है। उसको जल्दी हम
खत्म करेंगे। टेंशन नहीं लेना आपको। ठीक
है?
जल्दी हो सकता है हम एसओसी के रिगार्डिंग
आपके लिए स्पेशल कुछ क्वेश्चन लैब सेटअप
करें। आपको जाके जाके आपको सॉल्व करना
पड़े। लेट्स सी देखते हैं अभी। चलिए
चलिए गाइस। सो इट्स
दैट्स ऑल फॉर टुडेेस सेशन। थैंक यू वेरी
मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द क्लास। जॉइनिंग द सेशन।
हम जल्दी ही नेक्स्ट क्लास में मिलेंगे।
आप नेक्स्ट क्लास में आइएगा एंड इसको जॉइ
कीजिएगा एंड जल्दी ही हम एसओसी की
ट्रेनिंग को खत्म करेंगे। जाते-जाते जब भी
आप रिकॉर्डेड वीडियो देखिए तो प्लीज वहां
पे कमेंट्स कर दीजिए। 100 कमेंट्स का मैं
आपको बोलता हूं कि 100 कमेंट्स आप करते
हैं। सो नेक्स्ट क्लास हम लेकर आएंगे। सो
गो एंड पुट ऑन द 100 कमेंट्स। एंड साथ ही
में वीडियो को हाइप कर दीजिएगा। आप जब भी
कोई वीडियो देखने जाते हैं रिकॉर्डिंग तो
वहां पे एक हाइप का बटन नीचे होता है।
हाइप कीजिएगा। पॉइंट्स होते हैं। उसके
थ्रू वीडियोस को रिकमेंड करता है YouTube।
जितने हाई पॉइंट्स बनेंगे उतने ज्यादा
वीडियोस को रिकमेंड YouTube करता है। तो
यह एक हमारी हेल्प हो जाती है। एंड लोगों
तक यह वीडियो ज्यादा से ज्यादा पहुंचती
है। दोनों चीजें हो जाती हैं। एक
डिफ्रॉनिक्स की भी आपकी हेल्प आप हेल्प कर
रहे हैं, सपोर्ट कर रहे हैं। दूसरी चीज आप
उन तक पहुंचा रहे हैं YouTube के थ्रू जो
इस वीडियो तक नहीं पहुंच पाते हैं नॉर्मली
जिनको नहीं पता होता है। तो और शेयर कीजिए
वीडियो को अपने दोस्तों, कोलीग्स के बीच,
अपने उन लोगों के बीच जिनको इसकी जरूरत है
जो कि फ्री एक एक क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग करना
चाहते थे एसओसी एल1 पोजीशन के लिए और
अप्लाई करना चाहते थे जॉब के लिए और साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में एंट्री लेना चाहते थे।
थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन।
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में एंड गुड
नाइट। शुभ रात्रि। बाय।